apis have become the backbone of
software development making API testing
an essential skill for developers and
testers in this course Valentine despo
will teach you how to use Postman to
write and automate API tests from the
fundamentals of API testing to the
intricacies of automating these tests
using Postman this course covers it all
you will learn about variables scripts
debugging JavaScript Basics Json format
assertions regular expressions and more
plus the course provides valuable
insights into integrating Postman tests
in CI CD and the fundamentals of
collaboration within a postman workspace
so let's start learning
hello African campers and welcome to
this course introducing you to API
testing and automation with Postman my
name is Valentine I'm a software
developer with a passion for sharing my
love for technology in a fun and easily
digestible way in this course we will
dive into why automated API tests are so
important and how Postman can help with
that my goal is to help those already
familiar with creating requests in
Postman explore the thrilling world of
test automation with an emphasis on
writing tests and automating test
executions while this course is for
beginners it is not for absolute
beginners in terms of apis you will get
most value out of this course if you
already know what an API is and know how
to use Postman to create requests if you
are a total API rookie fear not free
code Camp has at least two other courses
to help you get your feet wet now let's
turn our attention back to this video
which wouldn't have been possible
without the support of Postman the
sponsor of this course for which I am
very thankful
throughout the course we will work with
an existing Postman collection write
tests and automate their execution with
various tools by scheduling runs
directly from Postman or by employing a
third-party CI CD tool such as GitHub
actions in other words we'll be focusing
on test automation
if you Ace all the assignments from this
course you will be able to claim a
postman badge that certifies you have
completed this course and are a true Pro
in test automation want more details
check the video description for a link
to the course notes there you will find
essential resources and troubleshooting
tips for when things go Haywire I will
also be posting any updates or
Corrections there after all this is a
fast-paced industry where change is the
only constant so if something is not
working make sure to check the course
notes first this action-packed course
will surely keep you busy for a few days
at least as always on free code Camp
please help us create awesome content by
liking and subscribing and hey if you're
enjoying this course do me a solid and
drop a comment below I'll do my best to
answer if you learned something from
this course I invite you to check out
and subscribe to my YouTube channel Link
in the video description below which is
packed with content about Postman devops
software development and testing also
don't be shy connect with me on social
media I would love to hear from you
don't forget the sponsor of this course
Osman their channel is chock full of
valuable videos definitely worth a
subscription so be sure to show them
some love as well
lastly a huge thank you in advance to
those who will support free code Camp by
clicking that thanks button and making a
small donation I hope you're excited to
learn more about automated API testing
in Postman and with that being said
let's get started
welcome to the world of API test
automation where we're about to embark
on an Epic Quest full of surprises
challenges and most importantly fun
I want you to think about this course as
a multi-level game where we'll conquer
each stage together and level up our
Postman testing skills to be a pro at
this you need to go through four levels
which will take us from manual testing
all the way to automation
we are at level 1 where we will use our
trusty Postman collection for some
manual testing
we will also need to get up to speed
with some JavaScript Concepts but don't
worry I'll try to make this as easy as
possible
the first thing I need you to do is to
open Postman for this I'm going to use
postman on the web so it's essentially
Postman in your browser if you go to
postman.com and log in you should see
something similar to this one
so in this case I'm logged in inside my
Postman account and I can manage here
workspaces and Collections and you can
see here that I'm logged in because I'm
getting this nice icon here
the first thing that I like to do when
using Postman is to change to a darker
theme so from settings
I'm gonna select here themes
and I'm going to select the Dark theme
okay this is just a personal preference
you don't have to do it but I'm going to
use this throughout the course
now once you have Postman open and you
have logged in into your account we can
now jump straight into the API
open the course notes from the video
description so in the video description
you will find their link click on that
link and you will be taken to a page
that looks like this one
located notes for this lecture
and then you will find a link that takes
you to a workspace
this is the workspace that we will use
throughout the course so it's important
that you know where to locate this link
to the workspace inside the course nodes
what we have inside this workspace is
the collection or an API
as well as various assignments that you
will need to do throughout the course
this is the postman collection for an
API named Valentino Artisan coffee house
I love coffee so why not create an API
for a fictitious coffee place
this API helps browse a list of products
view details and place an order for
coffee
of course in order to work with this API
all we have to do is expand this
collection here and we'll see here
various endpoints that we can use for
example we could use this request to get
a status of the API
as you can notice here everything is
grayed out and we cannot make any
changes to this
to make changes to any of the
collections in this workspace we need to
make a copy in Postman we call this a
form
so essentially in order to work with
this collection we need to Fork it
now before we Fork this collection it is
best to create a separate workspace that
we will use throughout this course
so from the workspaces here
you will have here the possibility of
creating a new workspace
I'm going to name my workspace free code
camp
API test automation with Postman
and I'm going to go ahead and make this
a public workspace
let's go ahead and hit that create
workspace button
so we need to switch back to the
workspace and to do so we're gonna need
to access that link that we have used
previously
so we need the link that we have used
previously so that we go to this
original workspace with all these
Postman collections
next what we'll do we'll go to this
collection which holds the API
and from the Ellipsis I'm going to click
on it and we're gonna get here this menu
and the option that we're gonna select
is create a fork
and when we select creative work there
are still a few steps that we need to
take
first of all we're gonna be asked how we
want to label this work and by default
Postman will give us a suggestion and we
can just go with that suggestion it does
not matter so much at this point the
next thing which is maybe a bit more
important is where we are going to
create this copy this work of the
collection and we have previously
created a new workspace so we're gonna
select that workspace so instead of my
workspace I'm going to click on it and
I'm going to select here free code Camp
API test automation with Postman
next you will be asked if you wish to
watch this collection
watching a collection means getting
notifications each time A change is made
in the parent collection
so if you don't want to be bothered with
emails every time I change something
about this collection it is best to
uncheck this
let's go ahead and click for collection
now we have our own copy of this
collection so for example if we expand
it here and go here inside the status
folder
we can click on get API status and we'll
be able to see here that
send is enabled this is essentially a
regular postmap collection where we can
start making changes as we need it is
totally independent of the previous
workspace we have seen it's just a copy
of the collection we made from that
workspace so let's go ahead and simply
click on the send button to see if this
API is working
so what you will see here is the message
Api is up and running
if you don't see this message if you see
at this point some errors no need to
freak out just refer back to the course
notes and follow some of the
troubleshooting ideas that I will list
there
but if you're seeing this message and
we're also getting here a status 200
okay you are on the right track
a postman workspace is essentially a
central point where collaboration occurs
within a team
we will use Postman workspaces to see
Run results write comments and generally
collaborate when working on apis
before we continue exploring Postman
let's first understand what API testing
is
API testing is a type of software
testing that checks the functionality
reliability performance and security of
an API
in simple terms we test API to make sure
it works as it should API testing is
like quality control in a car factory a
car must go through various inspections
and tests before it is considered ready
for the road we really don't want to
release a car that has no brakes
ouch
API testing focuses on examining the API
from the Viewpoint of an external user
the consumer of the API to ensure it
behaves as expected
the main goal of API testing is to find
issues and defects in the API ideally
before it is released and made available
to user
in this course we will focus on
functional testing in functional testing
we will examine if the API works as it
should from a functional perspective and
we're gonna look at individual API
endpoints and ensure that they respond
correctly to various HTTP requests other
types of testing such as performance
tests and security tests are outside the
scope of this course
before we can automate the testing of
the API we first need to do a manual
test we cannot automate something if we
don't know how to do it manually
in this lecture we'll go through all the
endpoints of this API and check if they
work as expected the idea of this API is
pretty simple we have essentially a list
of products that the coffee shop has
available and we can submit an order for
one or more products
we're gonna begin here with a status
endpoint because the status endpoint
tells us if the API is available tells
us if the API is up and running
so if this endpoint isn't working
properly testing the rest of the
endpoints doesn't make a lot of sense
and when we're doing this test what we
want to do is first of all send a
request see if something comes back in
the first place and then when something
comes back we're gonna take a look here
at the status we typically expect status
200 okay
and second of all we also want to take a
look in the response body to see what's
inside there so obviously this is coming
from the API it's telling the API is up
and running so this is already a good
sign it tells us we have reached the API
and this is a response from the API
itself
the next step is to take a look at the
products that are available
so I'm going to explain here the
products folder I'm going to click on
get all products you can also go ahead
and close this previous tab as we don't
need it anymore
I'm going to click here on send
so what we're gonna get here is
something a bit more complex in terms of
the response we're gonna still see
status 200 okay
and we're gonna get this relatively
large response body that you see here so
we can scroll through it and we're gonna
see here a lot of products coffees and
so on now there are a few things I want
you to notice first of all we are
getting here 33 results in total so this
is some information about all the
products are available
and these results are paginated meaning
they are not displayed all at once which
means that if we want to go through all
the products like the pages in the book
we need to turn the pages
so in order to facilitate that we also
have some information we know what is
the current page
and we know how many pages are in total
so for example if we want to go to the
second page
we need to use a query param so we'll
see here the parents are already
available the parents tab is already
selected
and one of the query patterns that we
need to set is the page so if we enable
this query param
you can tell us the page that we want to
fetch
the default initially is one but we
already have page one so let's go ahead
and change this to 2.
so now we're going to check if we have
page two so we are now getting other
products in the list and we can go on so
on and so forth through all the pages
apart from this what I want you to
notice is that each product also has a
category so there are a few categories
for example let's say we are only
interested in pastry so what we can do
is copy the value pastry from here
gonna disable the page initially
but this time enable the param category
I'm gonna paste here pastry
and what we're gonna get back are only
the products that are from the pastry
category
we're gonna see here the information has
updated there are several results
there's only one page in total and we're
getting this page
so if we go and scroll through this
we're gonna see that all the products
that appear here are from pastry
right so this is how we can get a list
of products but let's say for example we
want some additional details about this
croissant
so in that case we have a separate
endpoint and that is the get single
product endpoint
and what happens with this list is that
a product can have a lot of information
and we don't really want to display all
that information at once
for that we're gonna use the get single
product so that we get information about
a single product
now I want you to notice a few things
here so we have the base URL and then we
have forward slash products and then
we're using this annotation which
denotes a path variable
it's essentially something that's part
of the path is the address where we can
reach that particular product
so let's say for example we have here
this croissant and we want to get some
additional information so I'm going to
go ahead and copy the ID of this product
I'm gonna go to get single product
and paste this ID here
let's go ahead and click on send
and of course what we expect here is
yeah the name is the same the ID is the
same we're still in the category pastry
but addition we're gonna get information
like a product description which wasn't
available before or in this additional
text it's going to tell us it contains
gluten and milk all right so now we have
tested these two endpoints we have
tested that we can get all the products
and this endpoint also has some
parameters that we can toggle on and off
and play with them it seems everything
to be working fine so we can just leave
it as it is
and then we can move forward
now in order to move forward and place
an order there are a few things that we
need
but let's go ahead and open the orders
and this time to create an order we're
gonna use a post request now what's
important to know about a post request
is that the post request typically has a
request body something that we didn't
have before so far we were like give me
information about all the products give
you information about a single product
so it's like get get get get me that
information but now I'm saying no no I
want to place an order so for that we're
using a post record and essentially in
the body we're saying what we want to
order so let's take a look at the body
that is already here
you'll notice that there's some
information that's already entered here
now what's interesting here is that we
need a customer name so for example you
know when you're ordering coffee
somewhere you're gonna ask what's your
name so that I know to call you when
your coffee is ready so we need some
customer name
and what we have here is a random
Postman variable
a random Postman variable will generate
in this case a full name with every
request and it's not something
hard-coded like for example if we're
right here Jamie doe that would be a
value that is hard-coded this is
something that changes with every
request and we're gonna take a look at
that a bit later but just in case you're
wondering this is the Syntax for one of
this Postman random variables and apart
from this what we have here are the
products that we want to order so when
we want to place an order we need to
specify the products and we need to say
which is the idea of the product and
what is the desired quantity all right
so let's go ahead and submit this order
and see how it works come and click here
on send
and what we're gonna get back here is
403 Forbidden
and apart from this we're gonna get also
this error invalid API key
now this is a bit interesting because
this is not necessarily what we have
expected
we wanted to place an order but it does
not look like this order has been
successfully received on the other side
and similar to this we also have other
endpoints for example if you want to
check what are all our orders that we
have again 403 Forbidden invalid API key
now the question is
how does the API know who we are
and how can an API then show us all the
orders that we have
we need a way to authenticate ourselves
and this is a bit the topic of the
upcoming lecture
but in conclusion we went through some
of the requests in this collection
we have inspected the status code to
determine if the call was successful and
we also looked inside the response body
to see the data that is there to see if
that data actually makes sense
this is a very basic form of testing we
have manually tested if the API Works
which as I said earlier is a very
important step towards automation
so how can we get this request work we
need an API key which we don't have and
without it we cannot send an order well
in order to get that API key we need to
register ourselves with the API now in
order to do that we're going to go here
to the clients folder and we're going to
register a new client
now in the context of apis when we're
talking about clients or API clients
we're referred to entities that are
using the API a client in this context
is not the same as a customer so for
example for this coffee place API we
wouldn't have the customers actually
register themselves with the API we only
need their name in order to process an
order
but what we would like to register as a
client is for example a terminal where
an employee types in this information
in a more General context your Postman
tool and your usage against this API is
also a client when you are using Postman
to connect to this API Postman is a
client it's an API client that connects
to it so we now we need to register
ourselves with this API
now again this is a post request because
we're creating some data whenever you're
creating some data we're also sending
this data typically here in the body
what we have here for the registration
is an email we only need an email to
register also
now again here to test various scenarios
we have a random email that's being
inserted here so this is absolutely the
same as writing something like jamie.do
at example.com but Postman changes this
all the time with a different value
not so relevant at this point because we
just want to register our status with
this API
so let's go ahead and click the send
button
and what we're getting back this time is
200 okay
and what we'll see here is a token now
token is sort of like a temporary
password that's being used by apis
and if you're working with apis we're
going to come across tokens a lot
but what's important about these tokens
is that this is a secret this is
something that only we should know and
we want to make sure that we handle this
Secret in a very careful way
in Postman what we don't want to do is
we don't want to put the secret inside
the request
we want to store it somewhere else where
it is a bit more safer a bit more
protected remember we have created here
a public workspace
if we put here a secret somewhere in our
request
well somebody else can just simply grab
that secret and impersonate us this is
something that we don't really want to
do
now let's go ahead and copy this value
and what we're gonna do with it is we're
gonna store it inside our collection as
a postman collection variable
I'm gonna hover here over the collection
until this Ellipsis shows up I'm going
to click on it
and select here edit
and this will open up information about
the collection itself
now what we can do next is to go here to
the variables tab
and what we'll see here is origin entry
API key
well apparently we need to enter here an
API key and this API key will be used by
the collection so obviously enter a
valid API key is not an expected value
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
here under current value
we're gonna paste the value that we have
received when we have registered
ourselves with the API
and next I'm gonna click here
it is super important that you
understand the difference between the
initial value and the current value
because our workspace is public
somebody else can see this information
but from the outside the only
information that is visible is here the
initial value
in the initial value our secret API key
is not being exposed however when we are
running a request with Postman only the
current value is being used not the
initial value so this token that we have
here can be stored even in a public
collection and can be used by US when
working with Postman and sending
requests at others from the outside
cannot see this information
so in a nutshell it is always a good
practice to store any secrets that you
have in Postman variables and to make
them part as the current value unless
you want to share them with others
so now we have store this value so let's
take a look at create a new order why
didn't this request work
well actually it has a bit of
authentication here and the token that
we have provided previously is not valid
so let's try this request once again to
see if it works now
so now what we have here is actually
status 201 created indicates this order
has been created we're saying okay great
let's take a look at the response by
this to see what we have inside there
and we'll have here the order ID
this is our client ID so this is some
internal idea that the API has assigned
to us
we know when this order has been created
and we also know the customer name
and you're probably wondering well where
this Amy came from well this is the
random full name that at the time of the
execution postman has simply generated
this random name we submit this request
once again we're going to get a
different
and then in the lower part we also have
the products that we have ordered
still you're probably a bit confused
where does this come from how does this
work
well typically authentication is being
sent either as a query param so if you
look here at the params you're gonna see
no there are no query parents okay so if
it's not a query param typically it is
something in a header we can take a look
here at the headers
and again we're going to be uh no I
don't see anything oh well let's take a
look again you see here we have 10
hidden headers right so let's click on
this to expose this hidden headers that
we have here
let's take a look if there's anything
that we oh yeah look at this
x dash API Dash key so this looks maybe
like our API keyer that year so how did
our PostNet variable transform in this
header here that's a bit weird right and
you know how can we change this you know
if you're trying to make some changes so
it doesn't work okay so this is a bit of
the magic of Postman trying to make
things a bit easier for you to manage
but you know if you're encountering this
for the first time it can be totally
confusing actually this has been
configured using an off helper the name
implies it's something that's designed
to help you a bit and this is typically
configured under authorization if you go
here under authorization what we're
gonna see here is well the type is
inherited off from P it's actually says
parent so it's just a bit smaller on my
screen so it means do whatever the
parent does in terms of authorization
it's like oh which parent do you mean
well as you can see this request is
inside a folder which is called orders
so we need to look inside the orders
because that's the parent
all right so we're now inside orders and
what you see here have authorization
this is the tab where we're active and
what we have here in the list is API key
because yes we have an API key and in
this case the API key has a key name
which we saw in the headers also has a
value which this is how we reference the
postman variables with curly braces and
then this is added as a header and we
actually saw the header
the advantage of configuring this on a
folder level is that all the other
requests that we have can use this
without us having to manually go through
every request so let me show you for
example if we go here to get all orders
we expect here to see the order that we
have just submitted
so what do we see that is 200 okay looks
good and here is our Amy ordering
something from the API ordering
something from the coffee place
perfect
so as you have seen nothing has changed
just by placing a postman variable in
the right spot and correctly configuring
this request in terms of authorization
can get things to work again
now we still have one endpoint and that
is get order by ID
so you can simply go ahead and we
already have here an ID let's go ahead
and see if this works no we're getting
back 404 not found well typically first
founder font can mean two things either
this order really doesn't exist or
actually not our order
so if you're looking here in the list of
the orders that we have
well we have a different order ID so how
about we use that one
and replace the value here
let's click Send again and yes we're
gonna see here the entire order that we
have submitted
including the products that were ordered
which were previously not visible
so in a nutshell this is how we wanna
handle secrets in postman by using
variables and also using this auth
helpers which make our life a bit easier
and also reduce the chances that we make
any mistakes
we need to be able to write scripts in
Postman to automate the testing of this
API
API tests are written using Scripts and
automated testing is a way to check if
the API works correctly by letting
Postman run some tests instead of
running all these requests by hand and
checking the status code and checking
the body and so on
this approach has many benefits most
importantly it is faster and more
accurate because a computer can run the
same tests over and over without making
mistakes
computers are great at this humans tend
to get bored and start making mistakes
writing tests also helps document how
the API should behave or how it used to
behave in the past at least
now leaving all the benefits behind
let's actually start writing some
scripts but where can we do that
well let's expand here the status folder
and get into the API status request
in Postman there are two places where we
can write scripts the first one is the
prequest script and the second one is
inside the test
now what does pre-request script mean
okay it is a script well prerequest
means that this script is executed
before the request is being sent and
we're gonna get a bit into that why this
is important and which are the use case
but just keep this in mind you can write
them before the request is executed and
inside the test
you can write some scripts that are
executed after the request has been sent
and a response has been retrieved
so how does this look like well if we
click inside the prequest script we're
gonna have here this editor where you
can start writing some code the same
goes here for the tests pretty much the
same editor so this is where we can
write these tests inside this editor
here
in order to write the test here we need
to use a programming language called
JavaScript
Postman only supports JavaScript and it
is not possible to use any other
programming language to write this
Scripts
however JavaScript is relatively easy to
learn and also in the upcoming lectures
we're gonna go a bit into JavaScript so
if you've never written JavaScript
before it's absolutely fine I'm gonna
take you through this step by step no
worries
some people confuse JavaScript with Java
another programming language but trust
me they are super different and they
don't have anything in common apart from
this let's say unfortunate naming
similarity but anyway just keep in mind
JavaScript and Java definitely do
different things all right so how do we
write some code well let's go ahead for
example and start with what we're doing
a lot of programming language we start
writing like a hello world thing so how
do we do that well we can start typing
here something like console.log
you'll notice as I start typing you're
gonna get this suggestion so if you hit
enter
it's gonna auto complete with the first
option that you see in the list that is
console
I'm gonna write here Dot and there
another suggestion pops up and I can
even go and select what do I want to use
here so if you start typing log you're
gonna get only one suggestion and if I
hit enter once again
this suggestion will be completed this
is just a quicker way on how you can
type this and make sure that you're
making fewer mistakes alright so console
log is something that allows us to print
a message so I'm gonna go ahead here and
between parentheses and single or double
quotes I'm going to write something like
hello from the test
okay so this is the message that we want
to send out and at the end we're gonna
terminate this instruction with a
semicolon
in order to actually execute this code
we need to click on the send button so
that we run the request this code is
always associated with the requested
sound
so either we decide to run this code
after we have executed the request or in
the freequest script before we have
executed the request in this case it is
in the test so it's gonna be after the
request has been sent and the response
has been retrieved let's go ahead send
this
and we're not going to see anything
however what's important here is that we
are not noticing any errors if there
were any errors we'd see them here in
test results so for example let's
replace log with a capital l o g
just to make fun of this
so console.log I'm gonna send this and
we're gonna get here an error now this
can be super scary when you when you
encountering this so in JavaScript It's
always important how you write things
though things are always case sensitive
with apis with programming you want to
make sure that you write things exactly
as they are so in this case we're going
to get an error but
if we write the everything correctly
we're not going to see anything and this
is because things are going to be
printed to the postman console which is
the topic of the upcoming lesson
if you are writing script in Postman
there is a postman tool you absolutely
need to know and use and that is the
postman console let me show you how to
use the postman console to debug your
scripts understand your requests and
many many other things
so in order to open the postman console
we'll have to go here on the lower left
corner
and you'll see here console
so if you click here on console
this additional window will open up you
already see here a lot of requests now
first of all we don't need everything
that is already here so we're gonna go
ahead and click on this clear button
now let's go ahead and submit this
request once again
where we have this console log script
so what we'll see here in the postman
console are two things
first of all we'll have here the request
where we're requesting some information
and we can expand this
and we're gonna see here request headers
and other information from the response
the response body so there's a lot of
information about the request that has
been sent
what's important to know is that
everything that appears in a console is
in a chronological order so it appears
as it happens
now we have this script console log and
because we have written the script we
are getting this message in the console
hello from the test
because this is inside a test we are
getting this message after this request
has been sent
let's say for example that we want to
display a message before the request is
being sent so I'm going to copy
console.log I'm gonna go here to the
prequest script
and I'm going to paste the exact same
code
but this time I'm gonna write here hello
from the prequest script
hit again the send button
and what we'll see here is that append
it to what we already had in a console
we now have Hello from the prequest
script because this is being executed
before the request
then the request is being sent and only
then hello from tests appears here in
the logs
let me show you a neat thing about this
the thing is when we're working with the
postman console and we're sending a few
requests this entire log here will get
really crowded with a lot of messages so
instead of manually clicking on this
clear button over and over again we can
do a different thing so here in the
pre-request I'm gonna write here console
dot clear
and I'm also make sure that I'm going to
add here the parenthesis
so what this will do is we'll clear the
console with every request so let me
show you what I mean I'm going to click
here again on send
you're gonna see here
console was cleared
the request is being sent and then the
code that is in the test will be
executed and we'll see this here
we're gonna work with the post Bank
console a lot so it's important to get
familiar with it write this code
understand where it appears understand
in which order this code is being
executed
if you're no longer be in the console
you can simply close it from here
and if you need it again simply click on
it again and it will appear here
in this lecture we're gonna write our
first API test in Postman and actually
we're going to get a bit of help from
Postman but just want to get to the
taste of what is an API test so that we
don't talk so much about API testing and
actually start writing some
so I'm here inside the get API status
request I've opened up the test Tab and
we already have here this console log
message and we can continue writing here
code but what kind of code are we going
to write here well let's say that we
want to assert we want to check we want
to test
if for this request we're getting a
status 200 okay meaning the API is
answering back and saying hey the status
is okay everything is good you can use
this API
and we don't want to do this manually we
don't want to look at the status code we
want to forget that there's a status quo
we don't know anything about it when I
write a script and want to let postmen
do this for us how can we do that
well in that case what we can do here in
Postman is that we can open here a panel
so it's a bit hidden here on the right
hand side it's not already expanded
you'll have to click on this
you will get here a list of Snippets
these are useful scripts that you can
use
if you don't see the Snippets don't
worry about it I will also include the
exact same code that I'm using in the
course notes for this lecture
now if you can see the Snippets all you
have to do is scroll a bit through the
Snippets until you find here something
that says status code code is 200. okay
now before you click on that I want you
to go here in the code editor
hit enter to time so that we are here on
line 3 now
now you can simply go over status code
code is 200 and click on it
and by Magic this code will be generated
okay now this code is written in
JavaScript but it also contains like a
language that is easy to understand so
we have a test name which says status
code is 200. that's pretty easy to
understand
and then we have here something that
says pm.response to have status 200.
this is essentially the assertion that
we're making we're checking if the
status is 200.
so let's run this code again by
submitting the request and see the
difference
now because we now have this test
we are seeing here on the lower part of
Postman test results
we can click on this
and what you will see here we're gonna
see that we have different tabs for all
passed skipped and filled essentially is
going to tell us all the tests that we
have here for this request and we have
only one test status is 200 it says here
pass right it's even integrated here in
green one from one test half passed
so this is the difference the difference
between us manually checking if a status
is 200 or writing some code and then
checking here at the end has everything
back we only have one test so obviously
the difference is not so major right you
can easily tell if it's 200 or not
but let's say for example what if we had
here five tests or six tests right
Postman can do this in an instant and
tell us if all the tasks that we have
written pass or not
now again what we have here is
Javascript and now in the beginning uh
it may look a bit weird right
so the thing is we will look into better
understanding JavaScript so that we can
rewrite this kind of tests on our own
but I just want to show you how easy it
is to write your first test
there's one important thing that I want
you to take from this
even if we have used Postman to quickly
generate this code and we don't exactly
understand what it's doing it's
important that we ensure that this code
is working so how do you ensure that
this code is working well by generating
a status code that's not 200. so in this
case what we can do here is we can write
here status 2 for example which is an
endpoint that doesn't exist so when I'm
sending this request once again against
status 2 gonna get back here 404 not
found
and if I'm looking here at the test
status I'm going to see Zero from one
fail
so this indicates that postman has
executed this code which has a test it
has checked is the status 200 no it's
not 100 then bam alert it's not 200 it's
reporting this information here so that
we can easily see it
we are starting to automate this and
you're gonna get a taste of it real soon
so we have created this code here by
simply clicking one button
I already don't fully understand what
exactly is going on here how does this
code work and how we can write maybe
more advanced tests so to be able to
understand this code which is written in
JavaScript
and even write more advanced code we
need to learn a few JavaScript basics
in the upcoming lessons we will cover
some of the most important Concepts in
JavaScript that are relevant for writing
API tests in Postman we will cover
JavaScript variables and their scope
data types including object and arrays
functions and many other things you
should know now keep in mind that this
is not a full JavaScript course and
always check the course notes for
additional resources and learning
however with what you will learn in the
upcoming lessons you should have just
enough information to get started
writing code in Postman and
understanding such code if you see some
one of the fundamental building blocks
of any programming language including
JavaScript is the concept of variables
in this lecture we will learn about the
JavaScript variables their declaration
types and how to use them in our code
variables are like containers that store
data for us so that we can use them to
store and manipulate information in our
script
you can think of a variable like a jar
in a jar you can put something and then
put a label on it so that you know
what's inside so for example if you want
to store a name like Jamie that's the
data all we have to do is put JB in a
jar and put a label on that jar
which is like first name or simply name
so let's do exactly that in Postman
first of all I'm here inside the test
script so I'm going to go ahead and
remove everything that is inside here
and in the prequest script I'm going to
keep here console clear because that's
going to be useful
apart from this because we're gonna be
focusing on scripts I'm going to change
a bit to the interface of Postman first
of all I'm going to collapse this panel
here so there's an option here right at
the bottom hide sidebar
this will give us a bit more space
and additionally there's a different way
on how we can organize everything in
Postman and one of this is this side by
side pane so we have this two pane view
which we can click on it it will move
here a few things to the side so we'll
see here
the test results and everything but this
is something that we actually don't need
so we're gonna move this all together
and we can also collapse this script so
this gives us a bit more space to write
this code and in addition to this you
can open up here the console
so that we have here the editor and the
console in Clear View
perfect so let's go ahead by actually
defining a variable which is called
Jamie so I'm going to use the keyword
let which is used to define a new
variable so you're gonna write here let
and then we have to provide the variable
name which is like on the jar the label
so we can see here name
and then I'm going to use the equal sign
and between quotes I'm going to put here
the name Jamie
when we're working with strings like
names or any text or something like that
it is always important to put this
between codes
that this is when we have a string you
can use single quotes or double quotes
as you prefer now if we simply run this
code
nothing will happen
so it's important to remember
that if you want to check what's inside
the name variable then we'll have to use
here console log
and what we're gonna do here we're gonna
pass name
between the parentheses we're gonna
write name
in this case it is important that you
don't put quotes
so let me show you we're gonna click
here on send
and what we're going to get back is
Jamie so what is happening here is by
not using name between quotes we are
actually referencing the variable name
and then by referencing the variable
name we're essentially we're trying to
log this variable well what's the value
of this variable well it's Jamie okay
let's write that so this is why Jamie
appears here in the console
it's important to remember that this
code that we are executing here in
Postman
doesn't store anything anywhere this jar
with a label name will be destroyed
after the execution of the code so it's
available while we run this code here
but once the execution has stopped this
variable no longer exists so for example
here I'm gonna simply comment this code
out so I'm gonna write here forward
slash forward slash it essentially
ensures that this code is not being
executed it's commented out
and if I run this request once again
we're gonna get back here reference
error which is a JavaScript error
telling us
name is not defined
you are trying to log here a variable
called name but name hasn't been defined
anywhere so this is why this code is
failing this is just a demonstrate that
this variable only exists during the
execution of the code all right
so now these are the absolute basics in
terms of defining a variable and using a
variable
so how about we next Define two numbers
so let's say I want to define a number
which is called a
I'm gonna write here a
equals 20. and I'm going to find another
number called B which equals 30.
as you can tell
20 and 30 are not between quotes
but if we're trying to put here in
console log a
you're going to get 20. there are no
errors this is because 20 is a number we
can even
by comma separating A and B we can even
log A and B together
we're going to get here 20 30. we can
see two values at the same time
sometimes we want to create variables
that are the result of some operation
for example we may want to Define here a
variable which is called sum
and wanted to hold the result of adding
A and B so we can write here A plus b
so what we're going to do here we are
going to initialize a new variable which
is called sum but here we're gonna have
this mathematical operation which adds A
and B so let's take a look here at the
value of sum
we can add that to the list as well
you're going to see here that if we're
adding 20 and 30 the sum will be 50. the
advantage of using these variables is
that we can change one of the variables
we don't need to change anything about
that code
and then the sum variable will be
updated accordingly so we have here A
and B and some referenced in multiple
places but we only need to update them
once
sometimes we also need to join strings
together
say for example we have here a variable
which is called first name
and just as well we have another
variable which is called last name
so these are two strings now let's say
that for this person we actually need
the full name so we're going to Define
here a new variable which gonna call
full name
and in this case full name will be
pretty similar to the way we have added
two numbers and you may be surprised by
this but we can use here first name plus
last name
so let's see what's happening there
I'm Gonna Change here the console log so
that we can log this variable
we're going to see here in the console
Jamie Doe
now of course this is less than ideal
because there's no space between Jamie
and dough
but just as well as we have added here
first name and last name we can also
directly write a string here so we can
write here after the plus sign in
between quotes we have here quotes
and then we're gonna add another plus
sign so we are combining first name with
an empty string and with a last name now
in this empty string all I have to do is
press the space bar
and we're going to create a white space
so if we're running this code again
what JavaScript will do is you cannot
take the first name variable
take its value
then combine it with white space you'll
notice here between Jamie and though
there's a white space now
and then add do
so now we have defined a new variable
with a combination of two variables and
also something that we added in between
how we write these variables in
JavaScript is super important for
example you notice here that first is
written in lowercase but
n here in name is with a capital N
if we replace this
and have everything in lowercase and try
running this once again
we're going to get an error and
sometimes this can be so confusing for
beginners it's like what do you mean
first name is not defined I've just
defined it here it's right here I can't
even find it right so if something like
that happens always need to trace back
to what you have written and quite often
you're looking at the screen and looking
at what I'm doing and it's like no it's
the exact same code as you and mine is
not working
now the reality is that if the code
would have been the same it should have
worked the same but even just one letter
A Difference can cause the code to have
such an error right so when you're in
the beginning it's always a good idea to
Simply copy paste things instead of
writing them on your own because some
mistakes are a bit hard to spot and
especially if you're not working with
these errors and you don't understand
exactly what they mean can be a bit hard
so always if something isn't working
make sure that you really have
everything as you see here on the screen
no first name in lowercase and first
name with the first letter of each World
capitalized except for the first word is
called camel case camel case is a widely
used naming convention in JavaScript for
naming things
as it makes things easier to read it
enhances readability
so now we are getting pretty comfortable
with this variables and as the name
implies
a variable can change its value and
using a variable is super useful because
we can change the value as needed we can
change its values during the execution
of the script or you can change it later
on we can reference a value in multiple
places without asking it to hard code it
right so instead of having here full
name once again written like Jamie space
though you can simply reference over
this all these variables now the
opposite of a variable is a constant and
once we Define a constant we cannot
change its value so just so that you
understand what I mean by changing a
value so for example we have here first
name and for some reason we decide yeah
first name doesn't have the right value
that we wanted to have so we want to
make a correction to it so I'm going to
write here John instead of Jamie right
this is possible you notice here I'm not
using the let keyword anymore I'm
writing this code once again
and then I'm gonna see here we have John
Doe right so we can change this value
when we Define it once but because we
have used let we can change this now
let's take a look at the following
example
I'm going to replace here for example
first name
and instead of let I'm gonna use cons
I'm gonna say you cannot change this
first name right and initially the code
Works absolutely the same no different
but when we're trying to enable this
line of code which changes the first
name
this time
we're going to get an error here it's
like whoa
whoa what are you doing it's like you
have defined first name as a constant
you cannot change a constant
and this thing failed
so this is just JavaScript telling you
you told me to take care of this
variable and to keep it sealed there in
the jar and not allow any changes to it
and now you want to change it no no no
no this is not possible okay so this is
why we have this constant now sometimes
it does make sense to use a constant or
other times you don't need a constant so
in this case you know it really depends
maybe it's not the greatest example but
let's say how about you if you have here
something like year of birth right so
let's say I have here const we're going
to Define here here
of birth
and we're gonna say here is 1995 or 94
whatever
well it kind of makes sense if we're
storing information about the person
the ear of birth is Something That We're
Not Gonna Change right so maybe we're
gonna change the last name for some
reason
maybe we can change other information
like an email or address phone number
but year of birth you know that that is
a constant but it doesn't change right
the same we can store like how many
seconds are in an hour right this is
also something like a constant doesn't
change so whenever we have data where
from a logical perspective it doesn't
make sense to Define this as a variable
then we should use a constant
when we are working with variables in
JavaScript there's an important thing
you need to know about and that is the
variable scope scope is just a fancy
name for like where is a variable
available
for example we already know that this
variable name that I've defined here is
only available during the execution of
this script
the same goes for the prequest script if
we Define here a variable this is going
to be available only in the prequest
script we cannot reference it in the
test script or something like that and
also if we run this request and Define a
variable and we run the request again
and try to reference the same variable
that's not going to work because that
variable will be gone by that but still
within the same script so inside the
test here we can still have a scope
so in JavaScript we can Define another
scope so like essentially another area
where we can Define variables and this
is inside a code block so right now I
have defined this variable name Jamie
and I'm using here console log on name
and I'm seeing here the variable being
displayed in the console perfect
now what we can do here is put this
inside a code block so I'm going to
start here code block with a curly
bracket
and I'm going to end it with a curly
bracket as well so this is a code Block
in JavaScript
it is not very useful in this concept
but I just wanted to illustrate what it
means for code to be defined inside a
code block
so if we try here for example adding
another console log statement we're just
gonna get here Jamie Jamie perfect
but let's see what will happen if we
Define the name
Jamie here well we're gonna get the
Jamie Jamie
but what if we change Jaime to Jake
let's try it once again
and we're gonna get here
Jake and Jamie so what exactly is going
on here and why can we redefine this
variable if we already defined it right
we know this here we have the let
keyword two times what's going on
well these are a bit the rules of this
code block so what this code block
allows us to do
is to Define our own variables in the
code block so in this case we have here
what is called the global scope we have
a variable name
and we are here in the global scope then
we have a code block and then we're back
in the global scope so console log
will not be able to see what's happening
here inside this code block
and we'll essentially say okay you're
trying to log a variable name I know
here variable name I'm going to try and
print this out so the name will be Jamie
it appears here and here inside the code
block we have declared a new variable
which is called name it is just a
coincidence that it has the exact same
label exact same name as the previous
variable
but we can just use it here inside the
scope we can make changes to it and so
on so this is why we can see here a
variable called jig and we're going to
be able to access it here now let's take
a look at what happens if we remove the
first Declaration of the variable so we
only have the code block
now if this is the case all we're going
to get here is a reference error gonna
see here name is not defined
and this is because we are trying here
to access name from the global scope
and in the global scope this variable
hasn't been defined
now there are a few things that we can
do let's say for example well we only
want to Define it in the global scope
perfect in that case what we could do
here is we're gonna write here latiname
and if we remove here the lat
what will actually happen is that when
we're initializing here name we check
we're not defining a new variable but
we're using one from the global scope so
let's see if this works
we're going to get here Jake Jake so
what has happened here we've defined
here variable but we haven't set the
value
then inside the code block
we have set a value to Jake we have
printed it and then because this
variable is defined in the global space
we can also access this here
now I can totally understand that this
can be a bit confusing but you can think
about this code blocks like a one-way
mirror in an interrogation room you see
in the movies
the cops in the room can see outside
but the suspect cannot see in the room
so this is a bit hard to understand but
if there is one takeaway I want you to
get from this lecture is that whenever
you're noticing here a code block
pay close attention to variables and
understand where they have been defined
and I'm going to point this out also
later in the course but this is
something that tricks a lot of people
and they don't understand where exactly
is a variable defined why do I get a
variable undefined error and similar
things like that
so we're gonna start working with this
but in this lesson I just wanted to
introduce you to this concept so that
you can start getting familiar with it
and notice when this is the case
so in a nutshell
in a scope we can Define some variables
and nobody from outside will be able to
see what's going on inside that code
block Gonna Keep it like private like
what's happening in the code block is
only what is behind the one-way mirror
but what is happening here in the global
spaces is something that is public
knowledge for everyone so we can read it
in the global space but if we need
access from the code block we can also
see what's going on there
in JavaScript there are a variety of
data types that are needed to represent
information
this lesson aims to provide a basic
understanding of the JavaScript data
types you are most likely to encounter
when writing scripts in Postman these
are strings numbers booleans objects and
arrays
by understanding the usage of these data
types you will be better equipped to use
them when writing script
so far we have interacted with two data
types we have worked here with strings
for example in this case we're
initializing a variable called name with
the string Jake and also number and
you'll notice here that numbers are not
between quotes
if you're not sure about the data type
of a particular value
JavaScript is there to help you so let
me show you for example we can use
console.log
an inside console.log we can use the
keyword type of written together
and this will give us the type of
whatever we provide after this so for
example if you're trying to get the type
of name let's go ahead and see that
we're gonna see here we're getting
string
just as well instead of referencing a
variable we couldn't simply write here
something like
Jamie and we're gonna get back a string
we can write here 29
and we're gonna get back also a string
well the thing is 29 is between quotes
so anything that is between quotes even
if it is a number
it would still be a string from a
JavaScript perspective so not to make it
a string to make it a number we'll have
to remove the quotes
run this once again and we're gonna see
this is a number okay perfect so we are
kind of like understanding a bit how
things work
if a number has decimals we can write
them after the dot so for example we can
have here
29.65 and this will still be a valid
number
sometimes we need to represent the state
of something like on or off like a
switch that can only be on or off well
we could theoretically use a string for
that and say on off
but JavaScript has a data type called
Boolean
a Boolean value can only be true or
false so let me show you for example
let's say here that we are going to
create a new variable and let's
initialize it with is adult
and we're gonna set the value of true
if you want to check the data type of is
addled
all we have to do is use our console log
statement here
and run this
and what you're gonna get back here is
Boolean
super important true and false to be a
Boolean doesn't need any codes just like
with a number if we put anything between
quotes it will become a string
another data type that is maybe a bit
hidden and sometimes confusing is
undefined so this is something that can
confuse a lot of people so let's do for
example the following we're going to
Define here a variable is active
and we're not going to initialize it
with any value
so what value does it have
let's try it out gonna go here inside
this statement and change type of
angle reference here is active
and what we're getting back here is
undefined so undefined is its own data
type
and simply represents something that
isn't defined we don't know it is not a
string it's not a number it's not
anything else it's simply undefined we
have created a new jar but we haven't
put anything inside there
so this is the representation of
undefined but it's important to
understand this concept of undefined
because we're going to encounter it a
lot as you later see
now in this case we have a lot of
properties here that kind of belonged to
the same person right so we have a
variable name we have a variable age we
also have a variable is adult but it's
obvious that this data actually belongs
to a person
now in this case if we want to make
things more clear that hey all these
variables grouped together actually
belong to a person we can use another
data type which is called an object
so let me show you how that works
and it's quite easy so what we're going
to do here is we're going to define a
new variable to hold this object I'm
going to call the variable person
and in order to Define an object all we
have to do here is use this braces don't
have one brace in the beginning and one
brace at the end I'm here between the
braces I'm gonna hit one time enter and
add a semicolon at the end all right
so now we have here an object but this
object doesn't have any properties so
what we're gonna do here is going to
move these variables that we have here
I'm going to put them inside here now
you'll notice as soon as we do this
everything will turn in right because
this is not valid code
now what we're gonna do first of all is
remove all the let definitions in the
beginning we don't need that anymore
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to replace the equal sign
with a semicolon and we're going to also
remove the space before the equal sign
and last but not least we're gonna
replace this semicolon with a comma
except for the last semicolon
which will simply remove
this looks very similar to Json but it
is not Json it's super important to
understand the distinction between a
JavaScript object and a representation
of a JavaScript object in Json while
there are some similarities this is not
Json it is simply a JavaScript object
you don't have to trust me that this is
a JavaScript object let's go ahead and
take a look at the type of this thing to
see what it is
I'm gonna get back here object
all right so what can we do with this
object well for example we can simply
use here console log and we can log the
contents of this object so that we know
what's inside this object maybe we don't
know
so we'll be able to see here that we
expand this that we have here multiple
properties name age is adult and so on
now quite often
we don't need the entire object at once
maybe we only need the name for whatever
reason we're going to print a message
like hello then the person name right
so in that case to only access one
property we're gonna use what is known
as a DOT notation so after person we're
going to write here Dot
and you'll see here already there is a
bit of autocompletion that kicks in this
is because this object has been defined
here right inside the window
so let's select from the list name
and if we run this code once again
we're going to see here that the name is
Jake
perfect so this is how we can access a
property
now let's say for example for some
reason when we have created this object
we didn't have some information we want
to add some information later on how can
we do that well we can simply use here
person
and we can specify a new property let's
say for example we want to add a
property which is called email
so you can write person.email
and we're gonna initialize here this
property with a new value
so I'm going to write here something
like check at example.com
so if we log the entire object with
console log
what we're gonna see here in the list of
all the properties is also the property
email
and just as well if we need to access it
we can use the dot notation
let's say for example that we want to
have here email with the dash between E
and M
the written like this
now as soon as we write something like
this you'll notice here something turns
into red
and here at the end there's also this
indication that
there's something wrong with the code so
what's wrong with this code well
essentially when we use here and minus
sign JavaScript will think that we're
trying to access here
person.e minus a variable which is
called mail
and we're gonna try to initialize this
to a variable doesn't make a lot of
sense right
now in this case if we're trying to do
something like this we need to use a
separate notation there is a special
notation whenever we have some
characters that let's say are a bit
special and break our syntax that we
have here in JavaScript and for that
we're going to remove this Dot and
between square brackets I'm going to put
here email
so the idea here is that in order to
make this a string we also need to put
it between codes because otherwise
JavaScript will still think that e is a
variable and male is another variable
and it's going to try to subtract them
so even if the code now
looks valid you know if we're trying to
run this but we're going to get back
here is that e is not defined right so
that's also not good so let's put
everything between quotes
and now
what do we see we have here this
property email exactly as we wanted it
and it has right now the value that we
need
the same thing goes when we're trying to
access this property so if you want to
go here and write person Dot you'll
notice here in the list email doesn't
appear
so if you're gonna write here email like
this
well this is not going to give an error
itself
but again this is going to be like a
math operation where JavaScript will
think we're gonna get a property E from
person and subtract mail
so we're gonna get this time the error
that mail is not defined
you're probably wondering why is person
that he defined well that's not defined
but that's not gonna throw an error so
let me show you whenever we're writing a
property on an object that doesn't exist
like person.e it's a property that
doesn't exist this object does not have
this property what we're gonna get back
is our old friend undefined for
JavaScript not gonna say oh my God this
is an error you cannot continue just
gonna say this is a property that is not
defined
maybe you forgot to Define it or
something but it is undefined doesn't
show an error this is sometimes a bit
confusing because you maybe you are
writing here a property like is adult
let's say is adult
and you forgot to put a capital A there
you're looking at this and say oh it's
why doesn't this property work it's
right here in the object it should work
I've written it exactly the same oh well
almost exactly the same well that's a
problem if you're not writing things
exactly as they are inside the object
you're gonna get this undefined okay
we're jumping into too many things at
once but let's go back to how do we get
to this property so we know that this
notation with that doesn't work so we'll
have to use this other notation with
square brackets again when we're setting
a property or when we're trying to
retrieve a property that has some
special characters that break our code
then we have to use this square bracket
notation we're not going to use it a lot
but you'll have to remember it because
from time to time we're gonna need it so
this is essentially
more or less what we need to know about
objects here let's move this property
to the object itself so in this case
we're still going to use this notation
so we have to put this between quotes
single or double doesn't matter
and we can put the value here
then we have everything in one place
so this is our person it looks much
better
at other times we may need a collection
or a list of things things that are you
know kind of like similar to one another
and for that we can use an array
an array is a data structure that can
store a collection of elements each
identified by an index okay sounds a bit
confusing let me share an example
so let's say for example we want to
store here a list of hobbies currently
find here a new variable which is called
hobbies and this time to initialize this
array
we're going to open up a square bracket
and we're going to close one
now at this point we have here an empty
array so let me use here the postman
console
and we're going to write here Hobbies so
we can take a look at this thing
so we're gonna see here this is an empty
array some people think that this is
some error or something like that no it
begins and ends and there's nothing
inside okay so let's add something
inside so that we can make this a bit
useful so let's say what do we have for
hobbies num
not a lot of people do it nowadays but
let's say reading that would be one
hobby right so if we run this once again
we'll see here one so we have one
element here and this is a reading
perfect and what else we have maybe
traveling
and gardening
and cooking
now you can understand how these are
related to one another right so they're
all Hobbies so it kind of like makes
sense to put them in a list otherwise
would have something like hobby one
hobby two hobby three and so on and we
don't know in advance like how many
hobbies we have maybe you have none
maybe we have 10 maybe we have only two
so this array structure allows us to be
a bit flexible with how we store this
information
let's take a look again what we have
here we're gonna see here okay we have
four Hobbies perfect let's say for
example we only interested in the second
hobby how can we do that well in order
to access only one element of the array
we'll use again this square bracket
notation and this time we're going to
specify the index
so it means the number of the element in
the array so each item is identified by
an index so we're gonna write here this
is the first element this is the second
element so we're gonna write here two
and let's see what we're getting back
and we're getting back gardening this is
kind of confusing right so let's remove
this and go back to square one to
understand what's going on here now
indeed we have four elements here in the
array but if we expand this array
what we're gonna see here is the index
actually
now remember that in computer science we
always count from zero a race in
JavaScript are zero indexed meaning that
the first element is at index 0. the
second element is at index one and so on
so if you want to get the second element
we actually have to write there one
because you'll see here
traveling has index 1. no problem a
small hiccup so we're trying to get a
second element we're providing index one
and we're gonna get to this array
now again we have the situation that we
have a person which is an object and we
have this array separately
which is again a bit confusing
but we also have the possibility of
actually putting Hobbies inside object
so all we need to do is Define here
property
so
I'm gonna add here a comma so that we
can add something new to this object
column
and now we're gonna simply paste here
the array
so let's take a look again at the person
and now we have here a more complex data
structure we have an object that also
contains an array
so let's take a look at this one we have
here we have name age adult and we have
hobbies we can still explore these
hobbies and take a look at them
now how can we get to let's say the
third hobby right so we cannot write
here Hobbies anymore because Hobbies is
no longer a variable we have to go
through person we have person dot
Hobbies
and if we're trying to get the third
hobby then we'll have to specify index
two so this is how we can still access
this information from the array but
using the object which contains now this
array now there's one last thing about
the race
so if you're trying to do here like type
off
person.hobbies we should get back array
right
when we're getting object
that's again confusing right why are we
getting objects is it because this array
is now inside an object no it has
absolutely nothing to do with it
actually this is because arrays are
objects they are more specialized form
of object however we kind of like tend
to work with them separately and
consider them like separate things from
objects because they have like this
particularities that we need to learn
about and when we're interacting with
them they're super important but at a
technical level in JavaScript there are
also objects this is why when we're
trying to get the type of an array we're
gonna get back object
in this lesson we'll be exploring
JavaScript functions which is a
fundamental Concept in programming
a function is essentially a block of
code designed to perform a specific task
which can be called whenever needed this
allows us to organize and reuse our code
efficiently
so let's go ahead and Define a simple
function to define a function we need to
write the function keyword
followed by the name of the function
for example let's say we want to create
a function that greets us right so we're
going to give the name grid to this
function and then to make it a function
we're going to add here this parenthesis
and after this we're gonna start here
actually a code block which we have
learned about a bit previously and we're
gonna get to it a bit later
so this is the code block
this is where we can write some code and
this will be encapsulated so essentially
these are like gates to ensure that
whatever happens in this function is
isolated from the rest of the things so
for example we can write here something
like console log
and display a message like hello from
Postman okay so let's put this back here
where it belongs near the function I
just want to point out that this is
actually a code block perfect so now we
have this inside function our function
name is grid
or let's run this again
and if we're taking a look at the
console nothing like nothing where is
this console log statement what has
happened with it
well here's the thing just because we
have defined a function
doesn't mean that that function is being
executed immediately right so initially
nothing happens if we decide that we
want to call a function and reuse some
functionality that we have in that
function we need to invoke it or call it
so I wanted to call that function what
we need to do is to specify the name of
the function which in our case is grid
and not only that we also need the
parentheses at the end
this is what actually calls the function
and we can also add a semicolon there
so let's go ahead and run this code
and then we will see here hello from
Postman
so with this code here we are
referencing this function here named
grid
and with a parenthesis we are executing
that function without a parenthesis this
would still be valid JavaScript code but
we wouldn't be calling the function so
we'll see here there's no output that's
being generated
now our function is kind of like silly
it doesn't really do a lot let's make it
useful let's make it greet us how can we
provide some information from the
outside and make this useful
well in order to do that
a function can also think inputs in the
form of arguments which are values
passed to the function when it is called
so essentially when recalling this
function we can say something like we
want to provide our name so let's say I
want to provide here Val
and I want to say here something like
hello from Postman well do I want this
name to be printed there in the console
now in order to do that we also need to
change something about our function
so here in the definition between this
parenthesis
we're going to Define here a parameter
so we're going to call this parameter
name
and then in the console log we can also
reference that so we can say here hello
from Postman
comma space and then with the plus sign
we can use your name
so let's go ahead and run this once
again
and we're gonna see here
hello from Postman file just as well we
can greet multiple people for example we
can greet Jake
we can greet Jamie
and anyone else would like to greet so
let's go ahead and run this so we have
reused the same function
but by providing a different argument
we have also changed a bit what the
function does of course this is a super
simple example but you kind of
understand the idea
now I wanted to talk a bit about name
here like what's name
like what's name is it a variable is it
where has this been defined or how does
it work if you try for example inside
here to get something like console.log
name
it's not gonna work
you're gonna get an error name is not
defined but if you're trying it inside
here obviously this is gonna work
name here is like a variable
and this is why it's important to
remember the discussion that we had
about code blocks this is a code block
and this function what it does is
essentially saying here this is a
variable called name and we're going to
initialize it with whatever value is
being provided here I'm gonna say here
like name equals
Val right now of course this is not
actually happening in terms of the
syntax that was being used but it's
almost the same thing so for every time
we are passing a different argument here
this value will change
but it almost works the same as when
defining a variable but this is the work
that JavaScript does for us by using
this syntax by the way we have defined
this function so it happens
automatically but the idea is name here
is only available inside a function it's
not available anywhere else
okay so now we have this useful function
that's cool but sometimes you know we
have let's say for example we have
developed a super secret algorithm that
adds two numbers right so let's put that
in a function I'm going to give it a
name add and this amazing function will
add to numbers like like
let's call them A and B right this will
be parameters that we will have here in
the function because you know to add to
numbers we need to know those two
numbers
so this is how we can take input
essentially when we're starting this
function
so what are we doing with these two
numbers let's define a new variable I'm
going to call it sum
and we can add a plus b
all right so then we can use
console.log
and we can print out some and you
already know the drill in order to call
this we'll have to provide here two
numbers let's add one and two
and I'm gonna write and what I'm gonna
see here is three in the console
perfect okay this kind of works but
let's see if there's anything else we
could do here
so for example let's define two
variables let's call them number one and
gonna provide here one number
don't need a space here actually
this will be number two with a different
value
so let's say we want to display here a
nice message like
using console log
the result of adding
and we're gonna specify here
number one
with gonna add the next number number
two
is and let's say we want to call
this function at here so that we can
display everything in the message I'm
going to use here
the plus sign again we can reference
variables as well
so what we're gonna do we're gonna add
number one
and number two
perfect we still have here syntax error
so we need to make sure that when we're
combining Different Strings that we are
using the plus sign so the result of
adding number one with number two is
we're gonna call this function so we can
call the function
even from within console log
so let's run this once again
and what we're going to get here is
something interesting right
so we have here
58 and this is coming from here we have
console log so the function works it
adds these two numbers and displays them
but then when we're trying to use it
here it says the result of adding 24
with 34 is undefined again this annoying
undefined thing
which is driving us crazy why is this
happening why is the function adding the
numbers but when we're trying to use it
it disappears here's the thing
just because we use console log in a
function
it does not mean that the function
returns a value
console log is just useful for debugging
your code we're understanding what the
code is doing
but in this situation we actually want
this function to give us back sum
just because we have used console log it
doesn't give us some because we can use
10 console log statements right so it
wouldn't make sense to just randomly
pick one of them or just take the last
one and send that over
what we need to do is to add a return
statement so a return statement is used
to specify the value that the function
should return
after it is done whatever the function
is supposed to do
in this case because we haven't
specified a return value
well you guessed it by default
a function will return undefined because
we haven't redefined what we want to
return so if you haven't defined what
one return we're gonna get back
undefined so in order to not return
undefined we're going to use here the
return keyword
I'm gonna say
but what do you want to return how about
returning some
so when we're running this once again
we are keeping here our console log
statement which is useful for debugging
and understand what the function is
doing
but then
we also get here the value
which is being displayed through the
console log statement
so this is why it is important to have
this return statement in functions just
because you have added cancel log does
that mean that the function actually
Returns what you see in the console
we can also Define a function inside an
object so let me show you how this works
we have here an object with some
properties and let's say we want to add
this function to the object so that we
do something in relation to the object
so in order to do that things are
relatively simple we're going to copy
the code that I have here
I'm going to go here inside the object
and I'm going to Simply paste the code
obviously this syntax is not correct but
we are actually not so far off
there are a few things we need to change
now you can notice here that object
always has something like a property
and then a value
now we need to keep the same structures
we're going to start here with a
property which is grid the name of the
function and add it here and then with
column this is definitely going to
replace here any any equal sign or
something like that
we're going to say okay we have here
grid and grid is a function
that takes name as an argument
and does something with it
so if we're trying to access this
function all we have to do is right here
person dot greet
and in order to call it we need to use
parenthesis and grid also takes an
argument so we're going to write here
Jamie now let's see how this works I'm
gonna see here hello from Postman Jamie
let's add here another space so that it
looks well
and we're gonna get this to work when a
function is defined inside an object we
call it a method
while they look similar they're not
really the same functions can be defined
and called independently without being
associated with any particular object
on the other hand a method is a function
that belongs to an object and is
designed to perform specific tasks that
is related to that object so for example
let's say we wanna also display the
first name
right so we are getting some argument
from the outside but how about accessing
some information that is inside here we
can write here maybe a special message
like my name is and then we're going to
take the first name
so hello from Postman
Jamie and then we're gonna continue the
message
dot we're ending the first sentence my
name is
space and then with the plus sign
we'll wait to use here first name
let's paste it inside here
I'm gonna get this to run and we're
gonna get here an error first name is
not defined
okay
that's a bit of a problem we could use
here
person.verse name because obviously
first name is a variable it doesn't
exist so in order to get this to work
then we're gonna use here person DOT
first name
but let's run it once again and we're
gonna see here my name is Jake
now this has a minor disadvantage if we
for some reason decide to rename this in
person too from the outside we know that
hey this is person two so we're gonna
use person to that grid but here on the
inside maybe we forget to change that
so again we're going to get an error
here person is undefined
that's a bit unfortunate and exactly for
this reason if we're trying to reference
an internal property of the object we
can use a special keyword and this
keyword is this we can replace person or
person two or any other person with this
so if we run this once again we're going
to see here my name is Jake if we're
changing this back to person
it's still gonna work so it is an ideal
situation to use this if we're trying to
access some internal data in a method
that we have defined here
now methods and functions they indeed
look similar and they kind of like work
similarly but it's important to
understand what is a method and what is
a function even if they are kind of
similar for example when we're using
here console
doesn't log right oh well console is an
object we can write here something like
type of console let's see what's cancel
console is an object
which means that console.log
is then a function
and we're going to see here
it's a function but because it is like
technically in JavaScript it is a
function but because it belongs to an
object
we're still going to call it a method
right so we don't have this data type
which is called method and function but
we refer to an object that has a
function we're going to call that a
method and when that function is
Standalone we're going to call it a
function
anyway
console.log when recalling log here this
is actually the method log on the object
console so now you understand exactly
what console log is this is something
that's provided by Postman and it has
been defined somewhere else we can just
simply use it so this is an ideal
example for what it means to reuse
something we don't really know or care
exactly how this information is being
displayed here why everything is on a
new line why everything is nicely
formatted this is something that
it's a concern of this method it's being
put together in this method so that we
can conveniently use it whenever we need
it
callback functions are an essential
Concept in JavaScript programming
allowing us to write more efficient and
flexible code
Postman uses callback functions and it
is important to understand what they are
so let's begin with a few basics
the first concept I want you to get
familiar with is that we can store a
function in a variable
so what we're gonna do here is I'm gonna
Define here a variable let's call it say
hello
and I'm going to initialize it with a
function so we can simply write here
function
and what is our function
this will be our function code and we
can have here a simple console.log
statement which says hello
super simple so which means in this case
that
where what's the name of this function
this function doesn't have a name
anymore it's just stored in a variable
this is called in JavaScript an
anonymous function when a function
doesn't have a name it is anonymous it
doesn't have a name so in this case if
you want to actually run this function
if you want to run the code that's in
this function the only way to do that is
by using the variable where this is
stored so we're gonna use here say hello
this is the variable and remember in
order to invoke the function we need to
use parenthesis we're going to add here
this parenthesis and this is what makes
the call to the function
so let's run this
and we're gonna get here back hello okay
so we can store functions in a variable
good big deal why do we need this well
we're starting to get there
the next concept I want you to get
familiar with is that functions can also
be passed as arguments to another
function
okay so how does that work
let's say we have this regular function
which is called and do something right
so this is a regular function
and as you know a function can take here
some argument so we can provide some
inputs that we want to give to the
function now we in the past we have
provided like two numbers A and B which
we have added or we have provided a name
so that we can say hello Jamie but we
can also provide here a function we're
going to write here thumb function
because we don't know which function
this will be and here inside the code we
now have this function and we can decide
to run it
so let's write here a statement like
console log before running the function
and we're gonna have another console log
statement after running the function and
here in between we have here thumb
function which is a reference to some
function that we're going to get and we
want to call that function so in order
to call that function we're going to use
here you guessed it parenthesis
so now we are calling a function that we
are retrieving here as a parameter so
how can we do this well the next step
would be to call do something right
because at this point do something isn't
being called anywhere
and we can reference
say hello
so we are passing say hello
as an argument to this function which is
called do something
do something we retrieve it here will
run console log then it will invoke some
function
and it doesn't matter if the name is not
to say hello this is being passed here
as a value
it will call here this function that we
have here so let's run it and see if it
works as intended
so what we see here is that we have
before running the function this is the
first statement then we have hello which
is coming from here and then we are
after running the function
okay you're probably thinking oh Jesus
that's a really complicated way of
calling this function I mean why in the
world would you need something like this
and again we're getting there and I do
appreciate your patience with this it's
super important that you get this so
let's take it step by step
so to recap we can put a function in a
variable
we can pass a function to another
function and invoke that function here
maybe there's some condition here on
upon which we decide to invoke that
function it doesn't really matter
but these are like the first ideas that
we need to get familiar with now
what if we don't want to Define this
variable say hello
right in the past when we use something
like saying hello we have just written
there as a string for example Jamie
why can we not write the function
directly here inside this function call
well actually instead of using here say
hello we can simply copy the contents of
this variable
I'm going to remove this all together
and I'm going to paste it here
looks a bit crazy but let's see if it
still works
so it works absolutely the same before
running the function then we are running
the function and then after running the
function so now again we have this
Anonymous function
which we only need maybe one time and we
have passed it here when calling this do
something function
and what I want you to get is that this
function this code is not being called
here this console log statement is not
called here at line 8. it's actually
being called here
if we for some reason decide to
comment this and we're trying it once
again I'm gonna see here the hello
statement has disappeared so this is
what is running our function
this syntax is a bit confusing in the
beginning this is why I try to take you
step by step so that you understand the
syntax the way we write these things in
the end if we write here a function if
you write here a string jig if we
provide one number or even multiple
numbers it's the same idea we are
calling a function which is called do
something
and we are providing one argument so the
argument starts here and ends here and
then we're closing the function call
well the function call is this one let
me remove it once this is how we're
calling the function and here between
this parenthesis we are passing one
argument just as well we could be
passing two arguments or multiple
arguments same idea again you're
wondering why is this useful when I'm
gonna need something like this and it's
obviously not easier to read than before
well let me explain a bit why we went
through this effort of trying to
understand this callback function the
reason is that Postman uses them
so here in Postman if we're trying to
write a test
and I'm going to expand here the
Snippets once again
I'm gonna go here to the status 200 test
and add it here again now what you're
noticing here is maybe maybe something
familiar right so what do we have here
well we have PM DOT test well PM this
looks like an object
and test looks like a method right it's
starting to accept some arguments so
what are the arguments that this is
accepting well let me make it easier for
you to understand
so we're going to Define here a variable
which we're gonna call name of the test
and the name of this test will be this
one so this is the name of the test
and let's define another variable which
we're gonna call Maybe assertions
and this will be a function
and we can reference it here
this is what a postman test consists of
it uses the PM object
and then the test method which has two
arguments
it takes the name of the test
and a callback function containing
assertions
so assertions in this case is a function
what is sometimes difficult for
beginners to understand is this syntax
because it's not clear well where does
the method call start and where does it
end right so this is why I try to break
this down into smaller steps so that you
can understand where is the name of the
function this is the name of the
function right so I'm gonna put it back
together again so name of the test this
is the name of the test we're providing
it directly without using a variable
much easier and much faster to write
and then as a callback function we're
going to provide here the assertions
that we're going to use
and we're doing it like this
this is how we end up with this
particular syntax when we are writing
Postman tests
now I hope that learning about this
callback functions hasn't been a waste
of your time because now you understand
what is a postman test and how it is
composed and which are the arguments
that we need to pass in order to
construct the test of course we'll go
further into this test but this is why
we have learned about this
if you're not familiar with Json this
lesson will provide a quick introduction
to it if you already know what Json is
feel free to skip ahead
so what is Json and why do we need it
when working with most apis to send and
retrieve data we need to use the Json
format so essentially we use Json to
send requests from one machine to the
other
in this case
Postman is running on our machine and we
need to send a message to the API server
for example to order a cappuccino right
and then in order to essentially place
this order for example we cannot simply
say like we would say to a human yes I
would like a cup of cappuccino or
something like that
we need to format our message in a way
that the computer can understand it
let's take a look at an example so that
you can better understand what Json is
so the Json format is pretty
straightforward Json has a simple key
value format it is like saying first
name equals Jamie so we are assigning to
first name the value Jamie
but instead of using an equal sign we
actually use a column
and we put both the key and the value
between double quotes
and then we're still not ready but we're
going to surround everything with curly
braces this essentially creates an
object with one property
if we need to add an additional property
then all we need to do is create a new
line and separate those two lines with a
comma
you can notice that in this case 22 is
not between quotes
22 is a number and it doesn't require
any quotes otherwise it will become a
string the same goes for booleans
booleans true or false also don't need
quotes
the beauty of Json is that it is both
readable by humans as well as by
computers
you can read Json without essentially
knowing a lot about the Json format
itself
a confusing part about Json is when you
encounter square brackets
square brackets allow you to specify a
list in this case we have a list of
hobbies and you will notice that there
are multiple values between those square
brackets
inside the square brackets we Define a
list of things
can be any type of values like a string
a number a Boolean or anything else even
object
so let's do a quick recap first of all
we can see that we have keys and values
first name age is married and hobbies
are all keys
Jamie 22 Falls and then the list of
hobbies like Netflix and mountain biking
they are values
Jaime is a string because it is between
double quotes
when we want to add another property to
this object we must add that comma
otherwise our Json will become invalid
and the other party will not be able to
understand this message
so commas at the end of the line
except for the last line are super
important
22 in this case is a number
false is a Boolean and Netflix and
mountain biking are an array notice the
square brackets and individual values
separated by a comma
finally you will see that the object is
enclosed by curly braces one at the
beginning and one at the end
so in a nutshell this is the Json format
in this lesson we will dive into the
world of Json and understand how to
parse Json in Postman and how to use
console log to read a specific value
from the API response
we are done now with learning the
JavaScript Basics so let's transform our
Postman interface back to original state
so first of all we can enable this
single pane view by clicking here on the
bottom single pane View
this will put again the response here in
the lower part
and initially we can simply go ahead and
close the console
apart from this we can also enable
the list of collections that we have by
enabling here the sidebar
and we should be back where we started
let's go ahead and close the get API
status request and expand the products
folder and go to the get single product
what we have inside here is a product ID
so if we go ahead and try to retrieve
this we're gonna get a single product
perfect now let's say we want to work
with some information that we're getting
back from the API how can we do this
well what we see here is Json this is
the representation of a JavaScript
object Json stands for JavaScript object
notation
it looks pretty similar to how we have
defined an object in JavaScript but
there's still a few differences
now the thing is we cannot work with
what we have here if this is like a
pretty view that Postman offers us but
actually the data that we're getting
back is this one this here what you see
here is simply a string
and we cannot do anything with it we
cannot read a property we cannot access
any information or something like that
so for that reason we need to transform
this string that we see here into an
object that we can use now this
transformation from a string into a
JavaScript object is called parsing and
we need to do this promo Postman script
now the question is where can we parse
this should we use the request script or
should we use the test well the thing is
this information is only available after
we have sent the request and after we
have retrieved a response from the API
this is the response from the API and
this information is only available here
in the test in the prequest script
that's a bit too early so we need to go
here inside the test and do something
with this now I'm going to enable here
the pretty view again so that we can get
this a nice view of the information that
we're trying to work with
now in Postman in order to interact with
this there are already some predefined
methods that we can use so we're going
to use the PM object
and on the PM object we have here
actually another object which is called
the response so you see it's available
here on the list I'm going to select
here response
and there is a method which is called
Json
so when we are calling this method Json
it actually gets the response body and
transforms it in a JavaScript object
so this is what this method is supposed
to do
this method will return a value it's not
going to print to the console or
something like that so if you want to
use this for later on what we actually
need to do is to store it in a postman
variable so I'm going to go ahead and
Define a postman variable which we can
call response or response body as you
prefer I'm gonna go ahead and write here
const response
but this is actually storing the
response body just keep that in mind
all right so now we have the response so
we can go ahead and use console.log
and take a look at this response to see
what we have here
let's open the postman console run this
request once again
and what we're gonna get here is this
object which has different properties
so for example if we're trying to maybe
get the property ID
all I have to write is response.id
now what you need to pay attention here
is that we no longer have this Auto
completion
in this case Postman doesn't have the
information what kind of an object we
have parsed here what kind of a data
structure we have whatever properties
are available and so on so for this when
you're typing the code you're not going
to get the auto completion for this
reason it's always super important that
you pay attention to what you're typing
so number right here response.id
I'm going to get here the ID
but if I'm writing your idea with a
capital i
I'm gonna get back undefined so for that
reason what I always recommend
especially when you're getting started
simply copy paste the information if
you're trying to get here the property
is available just write response that is
available and copy that from the body
so you see here true though is available
is true and it's the exact same value
from here
if you are trying to get for example the
product description you need to remember
that this is a bit trickier right so
right here something like response dot
product minus description
this again will fail I'm gonna get
essentially an error saying that
description is not defined the response
that project will be undefined and the
description variable is also not defined
so in order to do that we'll have to use
the other notation that we have learned
about it in the past and put this as a
string
between these quotes
and then use this square bracket
notation so this will help us get the
information that we are looking for so
in a nutshell this is how we can parse
Json into a JavaScript object
and when we have a JavaScript object
everything that we know about JavaScript
objects still applies the way we work
with this object the way we read
properties the way we change things and
so on
previously we have seen how convenient
it is to set a postman variable and then
have a bunch of requests magically work
just because we have set the right value
this is the power of using Postman
variables
as you have seen where we have tested
our collection
there are a few things that we still
need to copy around so for example we
went here as all products and we have
found a product
and then what we need to do is copy a
value and then set it in the upcoming
request well while there's still a bit
of work to do this we can use Postman
variables and later on we're gonna even
improve this process so let me show you
what I mean by that so in this case we
have here this value product ID so let's
say we want to order this product but
first we want to check if this product
exists
so we're going to send this request and
checked oh okay this is the product that
exists and it's actually a product that
is available great and then we need to
copy the same value
and go into the orders create a new
order
and then put that value here for example
now let's say for some reason we decide
we no longer want to order this product
we want to order a different product
then again would have to search for a
product check that a product exists and
that is this may be the right product
that we want to order and also update to
create a new order request
we can slightly optimize this process by
using Postman variables so what I'm
gonna do here in the get single product
request I'm going to replace this
hard-coded value here
and I'm gonna set a postman variable so
you can see here if I select this text
I'm gonna get this context menu here set
as variable now if you don't see this
that's absolutely fine you can simply go
ahead and manually create that variable
I'm going to show you in a second how to
do that as well but if you see this
simply click on set as variable
and what we're going to do here we're
gonna set as a new variable
and all we have to do is provide a
variable name and I are going to be very
creative here I'm gonna just write
product ID
and in terms of the scope I'm gonna
select the collection scope so
essentially we're gonna save this as a
collection variable so let's go ahead
click here set variable
and now this is a variable of V hover
over this we're going to see its value
if you didn't see this context menu
which allows you to add a variable from
here no problem we can hover over the
collection name until this Ellipsis
shows up click on edit
and from the variables tab you will be
able here to Simply go ahead and add a
variable manually from here
of course later on if you want to change
this variable that we have created
earlier you can simply change its value
from here remember if you want this
value to take effect in Postman you
always need to change the current value
because this is the one that's being
used by Postman
all right so we have it now in a single
place here so what to do next well we
wanted to reference it here when we're
creating a new order
so all we have to do is remove this
value
and then I'm going to write here two
braces
and all I have to do is start typing
product ID
you're going to see here appearing in
the list of suggestions
and let's go ahead and submit this
request
so what we're getting back here are the
products that we have ordered and you'll
see here this is the product that we
have then referenced through this
Postman collection variable
so this saves us a bit of time in terms
of ensuring that a product that we have
retrieved earlier is also available and
we can manage all this through a postman
variable so let's take a look at an
example where we're going to change this
to something else
let's copy this other ID that we have
here
and I'm gonna go inside the collection
and simply change the variable here
so this time when we're getting a single
product
we're not going to make any changes to
the request just submit it you will see
here this ID has changed
and just as well in the create new order
we're going to submit this again and
we're gonna see here this ID has changed
as well
we can do also something similar here
with get all orders so from the list of
all the orders available we can simply
take a look and getting an existing
order ID in this case we're gonna have
to hard code one of these values so
let's copy one of these
I'm gonna go back in the collection and
I'm going to Define here another
variable which I'm going to call order
ID
and I'm going to Simply paste the value
here make sure to save the collection
otherwise the variable will not be saved
and then when I'm trying to get an order
by ID instead of having this hard-coded
value
can I simply go ahead
and select here from the list of
variables that are available order ID by
hover over it I'm gonna see what is the
current value that will be used for this
request
we can go ahead and submit this request
and then we're gonna see we're getting
back status 200 okay we're gonna get
information about this to order
maybe it doesn't seem so useful at this
point but understanding that you can use
post my variables to store this kind of
data that are coming from one request
and use it in other requests as well is
super important and we're going to work
towards eliminating this manual process
of copy pasting data
in this lesson we're gonna take a look
at how we can set Postman variables
directly from a script
just as a recap we have learned about
Postman variables and we have learned
about JavaScript variables JavaScript
variables are not the same as postband
variables while essentially a variable
is a way to store something they work a
bit differently JavaScript variables are
scoped only to the script where they are
defined and no variables are persisted
meaning we set a variable in a script
and then if we remove it we're not going
to be able to retrieve it once again
well this is why we also have Postman
variables Postman variables allow us to
store some information between requests
and even later on if we need so so for
example we can store settings and
persisting data on the long term such as
the base URL or the API key that we have
previously generated or any other
details that we need so we have this
information as Postman collection
variables but both my variables are also
useful for passing data between requests
so sometimes we retrieve some
information in one request but we also
need it in another request for example
here with the orders we're creating a
new order but maybe you also want to get
the same order later on and check if
that order has been properly created
that order ID is something that changes
all the time so yes we can use a postman
variable but we'll have to constantly
change this so let's take a look at a
way on how we can improve this process
the concept I want you to get familiar
with is that we can set Postman
variables from scripts so I'm gonna go
ahead and run this request once again
so let's say we have this value here
which is the ID of the order we have
just created
so we can go here inside the test
and here inside the test we can write
something like PM Dot
collection variables dot set
and we can either update or create a
variable if it doesn't exist
in our case if we're looking here at the
get an order by ID request we're gonna
see here we already have here this
variable order ID so let's try and
update that
I'm going to use here the name of the
variable which is order ID
and then we can also set here a value so
we're going to take this value that we
have here in the body
let's run this
you will see here this is something with
fb8t and so on
we open this other request
and we are hovering over order ID
we'll see here that the current value
has been updated
so we have updated this variable from a
script
now okay the problem with this approach
is that we now have another ID here so
if you're always trying to get the
latest ID and then get an order by that
ID
this approach is still not super useful
now in that case there's still something
else we can do we are gonna go ahead and
actually read this information from here
because we now know how to write some
scripts and we can level up our
automation game essentially by employing
this nice trick so what we'll do next is
we're going to Define a variable which
we're going to call
response and we're going to store inside
the result of parsing the response body
so for that we're going to use
pm.response dot Json we're going to call
it as a method so now response holds
this information
and whenever we're trying to do
something it's always a good idea just
use console.log
and what we're trying to do we have here
response
let's open the postman console
and we can see here okay we have access
to the response so it looks good what
are we trying to get we're trying to get
this ID so let's right here response.id
can we see this information here in the
postman console
yes we can here it is this is the latest
ID and you can see it's the same as we
see in the response body
all right perfect we're making amazing
progress
how can we update the postman variable
with this information that is in the
body
well all we have to do is remove this
hard-coded value that we have here
and use response.id
so let's see again
we are parsing the response body we're
updating a postman variable called order
ID
let's run this
so now we have this value I'm going to
copy it just to cross reference it
and now let's run this request you can
see that the postman variable has been
updated
let's click on send
and we can search here the body I'm
going to click on this one paste the
value that we have copied we're able to
see that is the exact same ID
so what has happened here is that we no
longer need to copy paste data from the
create and order request to the get an
order by ID if we're trying to retrieve
the latest order
so we can just run this once
go to the next request and write as well
this is the power of being able to know
how to write a script and know how to
use Postman variables to store
information between the request
we will conclude this unit with an easy
assignment
if you have been following along you
already did most of the work
now all you need to do is to go back to
the original workspace from where you
have forked the collection
inside here you'll see this list of
assignments that you need to complete by
the end of the course
completing all these assignments is
necessary for you to get the postman
badge that certifies you have taken this
course and have done the work
let's begin with the first assignment in
order to complete the first assignment
what you need to do is work this
collection so all you have to do is
hover over this until this Ellipsis
shows up
and from the menu select create a fork
make sure to Fork this collection in the
same workspace where you have also
forked The Collection containing the API
each assignment contains instruction so
if you're not sure all you have to do is
click on the collection
and what you will see here is the
documentation
just in case the documentation doesn't
show up you can also access it from here
since this is your first assignment I
will guide you through the steps you
need to take
so we already did a first step and that
is to Fork The Collection now the next
step is to actually read the
instructions that we have here so there
are multiple tasks that you need to
complete and these are things that we
already did in this unit
in a nutshell you need to put here
inside the API request folder some of
the requests that we have worked on on
the original collection
so what you need to do for example for
the first task is to take the get API
status request
to duplicate it here
and then to Simply drag it into the API
request folder
inside here we want to make sure that we
remove copy
so in the end the name of the request
should be exactly the same as here
now you will do the same with all the
requests as instructed by the
documentation so there are three
requests that you need to add to get API
status the get single product and also
get all orders
once you have done so
you can jump to the next folder and this
is where you can check your solution
this folder contains a request as well
as instructions on how you can verify
your work
essentially it is a way for you to check
that you did everything accordingly
this request also contains documentation
which are essentially step-by-step
instructions on what you need to do
but let me give you a hand
essentially this request here will try
to fetch your collection
and we'll do some tests on it to make
sure that you have written the code and
did all the tasks that were required
so let's go ahead and run this request
and see what is happening
now in this case we're going to get an
authentication error because we actually
need an API key to be able to use this
API
just as well we also need here the
collection ID this is an internal ID
that the collection has so let's start
with that one how can we get the
internal collection ID
well all we have to do here is click on
the assignment
and what you will see here is this I
button here
if you click on it
you will get additional information
about this collection including the
collection ID
so all you have to do is copy this
edit the collection
and go to the variables
you will see here that there are already
two variables that have no value
so for the collection ID I'll have to
paste here the current value
the next thing that we need is still the
API key so if we try this request once
again it will still not work
so what you will need to do is click
here on our profile picture
and select settings
and this will take us to our Postman
account
next from the menu we're going to select
API keys
and we're going to generate a new API
key
let's name this API key Postman
I'll go ahead and copy this API key
and go back to the workspace and the
collection
select the collection assignment 1
go to the variables
and in the current value
paste this API key and save it
let's expand the assignment once again
and go to the verify your work request
kind of go ahead and send this
so what we're getting back now is a
status 200 okay
and if you take a look here at the test
results
you will also see that some of the tests
you will see here an indication if the
tasks that you've done are complete or
not
now ideally you will start with this
once you're getting a status 200 okay
because this indicates this request is
working in the sense that it can fetch
your Postman collection
It's always important that when you're
making changes that you're saving them
otherwise the test that you see here
will continue to fail
so this is just a quick introduction on
how you can approach this assignment and
this is also valid for the upcoming
assignments as well your job is to
ensure that everything here will get a
pass sign and you do that by closely
following the instructions given here in
the tasks
always check that you are naming the
request exactly as indicated and that
you follow all the instructions I wish
you good luck with this one and if
you're encountering any issues please
use the postman Community forum for
posting about the problem you're
encountering and add there as many
details as possible so that we can help
you out
welcome to the second level in our API
test automation Quest where we Flex our
brain muscles and craft some tests that
will put our API to the ultimate
challenge
aren't you tired of clicking through
your Postman collection and squinting at
each response to see if everything is
working as expected
so far we have inspected the status code
and response body to determine if our
API calls were successful
a very basic form of testing we have
manually tested if the API Works doing
it once is fun but doing it multiple
times not so much well my friends buckle
up because in this unit we're going to
automate all this tedious work we'll be
diving into writing API tests using
Postman with Postman we can write a tiny
bit of code that automatically checks if
all the criteria with deem relevant have
been fulfilled will be checking status
codes
response headers and response bodies
we'll even dive into Json schemas
we're doing all this work now so that
later we can kick back and relax while
Postman does the heavy lifting for us so
no more manual checks or copy pasting
data between requests it is time to
level up your API game and embrace the
power of automation
so without further Ado let's jump in and
start writing some tests
in this lecture we will discuss the
structure of a test in Postman so what
do I mean by the structure of a test
let's open up the status endpoint
and start writing here test
now a test in Postman needs to start
with pm.test
and this method has two arguments we
need to specify the name of the test
we're gonna call it like example for a
moment
and we also need to specify a callback
function
so we can write here function
and this will be our callback function
I'm gonna hit here the enter key so that
we have a bit more space
and this is the basic structure of this
test now at this point this test doesn't
do anything this is like an empty shell
so we can go ahead and click on send
this test will show up here in the test
results you will see here the name
example but it doesn't do anything in
order to make this a test that will fail
if needed we need to write assertions
and we're gonna write these assertions
exactly here in this callback function
this is why we need this entire
structure
so how do we write assertions well
insertion is essentially something that
we expect so with an assertion we are
gonna assert something so for example
let's write PM dot expect
and we're gonna expect for example one
to eql which comes from equal
1.
so in this case we're practically saying
we expect 1 to equal one
of course this is a very simple
expectation and all the data that we
have is our coded but let's take a look
and understand how this works
so in this case the test passes because
1 does equal one
however just as well we could have here
the expectation that
2 equals 1.
or three
now in this case this test will fail
so the first test with the status code
will pass
but then our second test that we have
will fail we're gonna get you this
assertion error it's going to tell us
hey look 3 doesn't equal one and it's
gonna fail
a test in Postman can contain one or
multiple assertions
as soon as one of these assertion fields
the entire test is considered fail
once Postman detects a failure it will
stop the test and not execute the
upcoming exertions if there are multiple
of them
in this assertion we also have a bit of
a structure
what we expect here
this is what you will typically get from
the response so this is something that
we don't know this is why we need to
make an expectation about it and on the
second part here to equal this is the
part that we know for example maybe we
expect a product to be available and
then would say something in regards to
the product
to be true because available will be a
Boolean
the point of this initial lesson is to
get you familiar with the structure of
having a test and having assertions
inside that test
there's also something that you need to
pay attention
for example if you write something like
PM that expect
one
to equal one with a triple equal sign
this test will appear as it passes
however
if you write here 1 equals three
this test will also pass
what you see here is actually an
incomplete and incorrect way of writing
an assertion
so to write an assertion in Postman you
have to use PM that expect and you're
specifying here something then you need
to specify the expectation the value
that you think this initial part will
equal
just writing something like this is
totally incomplete and will give the
impression that everything is working
fine when actually it isn't
so pay attention to how you're writing
this test and make sure that you are
following the structure that I've
mentioned earlier and this is using
pm.expect
having something here then to equal
something else
let's turn our attention back to this
test and in particular to this assertion
as you can notice this assertion is not
using PM that expect it's using
something else well in Postman there are
a few expectations that we can write a
bit differently but probably most of the
time like 95 of the time we're gonna use
PM that expect
still I wanted to show you a different
way on how we can write the exact same
expectation but using PM that expect
now in order to use PM that expect
which looks like this PM not expect we
need here somehow the status code we
don't know from where we can get at
and then we need to write something like
to equal
when we expect it to equal 200 right so
this would be in a nutshell the
expectation
the missing part is this one here
now what we could do here is use
console.log and use pm.response because
this is where the response is being
stored in Postman
so let's take a look at what is
happening here
but our test will fail because we have
written here essentially undefined to
equal 200 and this will not work
but we have also logged here PM that
response so let's see what this thing is
well as you can see here in essence
pm.response is an object that has some
properties so we have here a property
status and we have here a property code
well we could use property code so let's
write here PM that response dot code
run this once again
and we're going to see here the value
200.
so what we want to do next is we want to
make a assertion with this one we're
gonna copy pm.response.code this is what
is coming from the response this is
essentially what we don't know
and then we're saying well we're
expecting the code to equal to 100.
let's go ahead and run it it's working
perfectly if you're writing here status
2 so we're changing the URL to something
that doesn't exist
this assertion will still fail
so this is just an alternative way of
writing the same assertion but this time
using PM that expect
welcome to the second assignment of this
course your job is to write a status
code test for Every request that we have
in this collection
having at least a status code test is
the most basic thing that we can do when
we're doing API testing so whenever
we're testing an endpoint the status
code test is the first test that we're
gonna write so this is why when we're
starting API testing we should ensure
that every request has documented status
code test which indicates what is the
expected status code for that particular
endpoint
from the original workspace I have
Linked In the course notes you need to
Fork The Collection named assignment 2
and follow the instructions from there
before we start doing something with the
response body it is best not to assume
we get Json Bank
sometimes the API might misbehave and
return something unexpected like HTML
let me show you
I'm gonna go ahead and expand the
products folder
and take a look at the get single
product where we already inside the test
have some code where we're parsing the
response body and then we're trying to
log property
now typically if we're getting back Json
this works without any issues
however let's make a change to this
instead of products here I'm going to
write here products too
and I'm going to go ahead and submit
this request
now what we're getting back here
is a status 404 not found
and apart from this we're getting back
here HTML
this is essentially what's being used to
display web pages and this API is not
perfect and in some situations does
return back HTML without knowing that
we're not really interested in HTML
still we need to be prepared for such
situations
apart from this what I want you to
notice is that here the test results
appear in red now even though we haven't
written any tests
we're gonna get this nasty error here
telling us there was an error evaluating
the test script and there's some
problems here when we're writing code in
Postman it is best to encapsulate this
in a test
if an error occurs in a test it's not
going to propagate outside of the test
though essentially that callback
function provides some protection around
the code that we're writing
let me show you what I mean so we're
gonna write here a test
where we want to assert that the
response body is Json so I'm going to
write pm.test
and then right here response body is
Json
so this is the first argument
then I'm gonna write the Callback
function
and inside the Callback function let's
move our test
so I know that currently this code is
not properly working
now let's send this once again
and this time what we're gonna get back
is a test result and we're gonna get the
information that this test here which
doesn't contain any assertions but the
code that is inside this test has
actually failed and we're getting here a
Json error and it is practically the
same error but what's important here to
notice is that this code doesn't prevent
other code that we have inside our test
from running
so any errors that appear will be
limited to this callback function
still this is not a way of actually
testing if the response body is Json so
in order to test if the response body is
Json we actually need to write an
assertion and this is again one of these
special assertions that don't use PM
that expect in this case we're going to
write pm.response
to B
Json super easy to read and also super
easy to write
let's run this once again and see what
is happening
and in this case now the test is still
failing this is expected but we're gonna
get here this assertion error it's gonna
tell us expected response body to be a
valid Json but God error unexpected
token at something okay and if this
assertion here fails this code here is
no longer being executed
so when we're working with Json and we
expect to get back Json from an API
it is not a bad idea to start with a
test where we are checking that the
response body is Json the resource
button is not Json you shouldn't worry
with further assertions because we're
gonna get some unexpected errors
just testing if the status is 200 or
checking that we're getting back Json is
not enough to really verify that an
endpoint is working as expected
sometimes we want to wish if a property
from the response has an expected value
so how can we do that
let's take a look at the response once
again
and in this case I'm just grabbing a
product here it doesn't really matter
which product it is but I'm having here
Bagel so I would like to check that this
property name
is actually bagel let's go ahead and
write a test pm.test and the name of the
test will be productivism
and I'm gonna also add here the Callback
function
perfect so in order to write these
assertions first of all we need access
to the response body
and as you have seen here we already
passed the response once so
theoretically we would be able to use it
here as well we can use pm.expect I'm
gonna write here response
and from the response what are we trying
to get we're trying to get here the
property name
I'm gonna write here 2 equal
and we're going to hard code the value
bail
if you're using a different product make
sure to specify a different value
let's go ahead and run this and
surprisingly this test is failing and
we're getting here this reference error
response is not defined but response is
defined how come it doesn't work here
well this is where understanding the
JavaScript Basics are super important
remember those code blocks well when we
are here inside the function we are
essentially inside the code block so
whatever we Define here is not going to
be available somewhere else still if we
put this outside that's going to cause
other problems because we're gonna try
to parse the response without knowing if
it is actually a valid Json
so what we could do in this case
is simply Define here
response outside we're gonna remove here
const
and this time I'm going to use let
response because we're changing its
value we cannot Define it with const
so we have here let outside in the
global scope
which means we have access in our
callback functions to this so then we
can use response.name let's give it
another try
and we're going to see here response
body is Json
product is beagle this is passing
without any issues
just as well we can take a look at
another property for example let's say
we want to check the price so we're just
going to go ahead and simply copy paste
the same expectation that we had before
and you notice me I'm using here copy
paste
always use copy paste when you're
working with properties from the
response body because this ensures
you're not making any mistakes
so response at price
well what is the price it's going to be
195.
so let's put that price here
and run this once again
and again this test is failing why is it
failing
because 195 does not deeply equal 195
and this can be a bit of a confusing
error how do you mean well 195 in the
body doesn't have any quotes which means
is a number
here 195 is between quotes which means
it is a string when we're comparing
things in JavaScript a string will never
equal a number
even if the value is the same so in
order to get this to work all we have to
do is remove this quote
and then our restoration will work
just as well okay continue also with
other assertions for example we could
check if this is available so you'll
notice here I'm grouping multiple
assertions under the same test so maybe
later on we can decide to change the
name of the test but we're just trying
to understand how these assertions are
actually working so let's go ahead and
start here that this property is
available
is actually true so again true is a
Boolean so we don't need any quotes we
can put it like this
so the test will continue to pass
or an alternative way to write this is
to still use PM that expect instead of
writing to equal we can write to B
true
different syntax Works absolutely the
same
if you would think that this is for some
reason false we can write this false but
of course in this case the test is
failing it's a good idea to test our
assertions to make sure that they're
actually work the way we expect them to
work
now there's still one thing that I would
like to test here and that is we have
here this Postman collection variable
with the product ID and we manage this
somewhere so we can change this later on
so how can we ensure that the product
that we have requested by specifying
this product ID is also the one that
we're getting here in the body now of
course we can check all these properties
name and so on but maybe testing out the
ID would be a good idea as well so let's
write here pm.expect
what are respecting we're expecting
response dot ID to equal
and
what is the name of the variable let's
go ahead and copy paste this
and put it inside here
okay maybe we need some quotes no
problem
let's put this between quotes
no errors I'm gonna give it a try
and the test is failing
what is happening in this case
why is this working here when we're
sending the request
but when we're putting this inside our
test is not working anymore
well what's important to remember is
that this syntax
only works in the request Builder
essentially you can use this Syntax for
variables when we're working with params
with path variables with authorization
headers in the body
anywhere else apart from the script we
cannot use this syntax in the script
it's simply a string Postman is not
going to replace it
so if we're trying to get the product ID
in a programmatic way essentially from a
script
we need to use something similar to The
Way We have set a variable from the
script we can use
pm.colection variables because this is a
collection variable and this time we're
going to use get
we're going to specify okay what are we
trying to get trying to get a product ID
let's give it a chance
now there's something even more
interesting you can see now we're
getting the value right
but we're getting this problem that
we've seen before when we're comparing a
number with a string
if you're looking here inside a
collection at the variables
you'll notice that you know there are no
quotes here
and the question is why doesn't this
work
well the thing where we're manually
managing information here most of the
time behind the scenes Postman will save
this as a string
and then when we are making comparisons
here then we're gonna get a string and
we're gonna compare string with a number
and that's not gonna work
if we want to rescue the situation and
we are pretty sure that we have a string
there we can use a function which is
called parse int so with parse end it's
gonna try to transform that string into
a number into an integer
then we can run this and our assertion
is working because now we're comparing a
number with another number
now let's go ahead and change this
product to some other product
you will see here we are using the
product ID so what we need to do is to
figure out another valid product ID say
for example let's disable the category
that we have enabled
and let's simply go with the cappuccino
so we have here this ID for a cappuccino
I'm gonna go inside the collection and
edit the variables I'm Gonna Change here
the product ID to a different value I'm
going to go ahead and save it and let's
get a single product so now we expect to
get back cappuccino if we're taking a
look at the body
yes we have a cappuccino
and yeah the response body looks
absolutely fine
now if you're taking a look at the test
results they are not so fine well okay
it says here product is a bagel and we
have here some tests that verify
some parameters well the thing is the
response itself is still fine it still
looks like a valid response
it just isn't a bagel now we can debate
if this is a good test or a bad test but
this for our situation here this test is
overly specific if there's any change in
the data for example maybe the price is
changing or the product name is slightly
changing then our test will fail
so the only Dynamic part that we have
here inside our test are the product ID
and of course it's always a good idea to
assume that a product that we're trying
to work with is available but the name
and the price they are problematic there
are situations like this one where it
makes little sense to hard code values
in tests
do we really care if the product is
called a bagel or a cappuccino or how
much it costs
and in most cases reality is we don't
we just want to check if the product
that we have received is a valid product
so instead of asserting if a property
has a specific value
we can change our assertion to check the
data type of that property so let me
give an example
we know that the response body has a
property called name
so let's check if there is a property
code name there instead of just checking
it has a specific value
so to do that we can write here another
expectation so I'm gonna remove here
bagel
and the expectation that I'm gonna write
is PM that expect
and the expectation goes against the
response because this is the object that
contains the product
and we can write here to have property
and the property is name and for a
second I'm also then remove this price
from here
so now we are just checking if the
response has a property called name
and the test is passing we can check
also if it has property called Product
name
and if we run this the test will fail
because there is no property product
name in the response body we can check
that easily
so there's only a property called name
now we don't only care that we have a
property called name but we also care if
this name property is actually a string
so we can write another expectation but
this time on the property we can see PM
not expect
and we have response dot name
and we can say here 2B oh
and then as a string we're going to
write here strings we're going to have
here string between quotes
so we're checking if the response body
has a property called name and we're
checking that this property is a string
and it is a string we can also check if
it is a number
and this is not a number it is actually
a string
so we're gonna get this assertion error
so let's switch it back to string
in a similar fashion we can also go
about the price
so instead of checking a specific price
we can simply go ahead and D here if the
responsive price
to be a number
and the price indeed is a number so the
test is passing and now from a logical
sense we typically expect our price to
be higher than zero right so no price
can be zero or we can't have any
negative prices this is just the
business logic that we have we are
trying to make a profit so we're not
going to sell something where we have to
give mine to the customer right so it's
a valid expectation to say whatever
price we have it must be at least one
cent so it needs to be greater than zero
so we can write here another expectation
with PM that expect against the response
price
2 B and we have here greater than
always follow the auto completion to be
faster and more accurate
I'm gonna write here the price to be
greater than zero
the test is passing now this product
costs three dollars so let's change it
for example to let's say four here to be
greater than four and it's not going to
be greater than 4 because 3 is not above
4.
so we have also tested that the
assertion that we have written makes
sense from this perspective
now of course we have grouped here a lot
of assertions around this test but we
can just also split them for example we
can write a test that only deals with
price to ensure that it has a valid
price we can write a test that just
ensures that a property is as expected
and so on so we're not going too much
into how we organize this test and how
we name things but we're just trying to
understand how we can write these
assertions better
and now the advantage of this approach
is that we can change the product and
the test will still work only if
something changes about the structure of
the data will we have issues
now you notice here that this syntax is
relatively easy to read right so maybe
you don't know exactly how to write
everything but once something is written
you can just look at it and say oh
response to have property name that's
understandable response that name to be
a string that's also understandable well
what makes these assertions work so well
and be so easily readable is a
third-party library that is being used
by Postman so this easy to read syntax
is made possible by a JavaScript
assertion Library named chai JS and you
can find out more about chijs at
chijs.com and I also linked this
documentation in the course notes so
what you will find here are many many
other options that you can use now
you'll notice here that the
documentation uses expect to equal so
the only thing that you need to get
something like this working in post is
to Simply add here PM don't expect and
it will work in Postman so let me show
you an example here just to understand
we can copy this assertion here take it
inside Postman if you paste it as it is
we're gonna get an error telling us that
expect is not defined so all you have to
do is add pm.expect
getting familiar with the chai assertion
library is a very powerful way of
writing more sophisticated Postman tests
and this is a very powerful assertion
Library so do spend some time and go
over the examples that are being listed
here I'm sure you will find something
useful
let's take a look for a second at the
create an order request
inside this request we have a few
interesting things when one of these
things is here this variable which is a
postman generated random variable it's
not a variable that we are setting
however how can we guarantee that the
data that we're sending has actually
been received by the API exactly as we
intended
well let's go ahead and see how we can
write a test for this particular use
case
we're going to begin with a few Basics
and we're gonna borrow from one of the
previous requests that we have and this
comes from the products endpoint
for what we already have here is this
part with response body is Json so this
is something that's super useful we want
to make sure that the response body is
Json so we're parsing the response body
and storing this in a variable and of
course once the response body is Json
maybe we also want to set this Postman
variable here but that's not the scope
of it let's go ahead and write a new
test that verifies the customer name
so let's name the test simply customer
name
and we're going to have here our
callback function
and we can start writing some assertions
so how do we write an assertion well we
can go ahead and use pm.expect
and what do we have here well we have
the response
and on the response we have the property
customer name that we can use perfect so
far so good and then we write 2 equal
and then
what do we put inside here well we could
try something like this right so we
could go ahead and put this as a string
inside here and see what is happening
and what is happening is that we're
gonna get a test that is failing
so this syntax doesn't work inside here
it works inside the body but doesn't
work inside here
still there is a way to resolve Postman
variables like this one inside Scripts
the syntax is a bit tricky but I'm going
to show you anyway
so what we need to use is
pm.variables dot replace in it's a bit
tricky but hang on for a second so we're
going to replace in
and here we can essentially specify a
string pretty similar to what we have
here so if you're unsure about the
outcome of this we can simply wrap
everything in a console.log statement
and take a look in the postman console
to see what is happening
let's clear everything here and run this
so what you will see here being logged
is the result of us writing this line of
code so this is a way how we can still
use this syntax with braces without
using pm.collection variables.get or
something and when we're working with
this random Postman variables there is
any way no other alternative to reaching
one of these values
all right so you can see here that we
are now getting this random Postman
variable and it changes all the time so
we can simply go ahead and use this in
our code
so we're gonna stay here pm.variables
replace in
and we have our expectation
right about here
let's run it once again
and our test is still failing and the
reason for that is whenever Postman
invokes this call when we say we want to
use here random full name or random
something else a new value is generated
with every call so Postman generates one
value here in the body
and in the test it's going to generate a
different value so this is why our test
is still failing
we haven't made a lot of progress have
we well not so fast I have a different
idea I'm going to go ahead and copy this
from here
and
I'm gonna go here in the prequest script
so here in the prequest script what we
could do
is to set another Postman collection
variable we can use here pm.collection
variables.set
and we could call this customer name and
the value would be you know whatever
comes back from here and then in the
body
we can replace this random variable here
with a collection variable which
currently doesn't exist but it will
exist in a second
and also in the test we can use BMW
collection variables dot get
and we're getting the customer name
so we're letting Postman generate this
once
set it in a postman collection variable
by using it in the body and we're using
it in assertion let's give it a try to
see if it works
and what do you see this is how we can
take advantage of random Postman
variables and Postman collection
variables to pass data between the
prequest to request the tests and so on
let's continue thinking about what kind
of tests we could write against this
particular endpoint so we know that we
have the right customer name and of
course there's also other details that
we could check
but one interesting one would be this ID
this ID is the order ID and it does
follow some rules for example this order
ID can only be composed of uppercase
letters and numbers and it has a fixed
size of nine characters
so how can we write a test for something
like this
well let's go ahead and copy the
skeleton for a test and we can write
here something like order
ID
format
so we're testing the format of the order
ID
how can we do that well we can again use
PM that expect a response
dot ID
and then what we could do here is to
write a regular expression
now regular expression is a way how you
can Define in a programmatic way the
kind of structure that you expect from
data in this case we can write a regular
expression that says this ID can only
contain numbers and letters and those
letters need to be in uppercase and the
size of this thing needs to be nine
characters
we're not going to go into how we can
write regular Expressions because that's
a topic on its own but we're going to
take a look at a simple example at how
to do this in Postman so what we're
going to use here is to match so to
match allows us to write a regular
expression
and we're gonna write it here and I want
you to pay attention this is not a
string here what we're writing inside
match
so a regular expression goes more or
less like this
we are starting it here then we're
adding here this carrot sign
and then what we'll have here between
brackets we're gonna say something like
this must contain letters from A to Z
and from n numbers from 0 to 9.
and we expect to see this exactly nine
times
and this is the end of the regular
expression you'll see here I have no
errors if you're having trouble finding
any of these characters on your keyboard
don't worry I've added this expression
to the course notes as well so that you
can easily copy paste it if needed
so let's take a look and see if this is
working as expected
I'm gonna go ahead and click on send
and you'll see the test is passing
now the thing is I know that this API
has a bug and from time to time in the
ID it will include a character that is
not a letter from A to Z or a number
from 0 to 9. so it's just a matter of
time until you're running this test
and you're noticing all of the sudden
this test failing because you will find
there a character that shouldn't be
there oh there it is look have you
spotted it
you'll see initially the test has passed
but after a while we are getting this
Dash here and this is not something that
we expect according to how this ID
should work
so this is why it's a good thing to have
a test here that will fail and warn us
if all of the sudden something changes
about the behavior of this API
it is now time for the third assignment
and for you to get some Hands-On
practice we have gone through various
ways of testing the API endpoints and
writing various tests and assertions
now I want you to go inside the orders
endpoint
and take a look at this get an order by
ID request
in this case you're getting here back
information about this order and I want
you to use everything that you have
learned so far to write some tests
make sure that you go to the original
workspace and work the collection named
assignment 3.
let's continue exploring ways on how we
can test this endpoint so I'm here at
the create a new order endpoint and we
are checking out the response buddies
Json we are checking the customer name
and we're also checking that the order
ID has the right format but there's
still also other information here
how can we do that
well in order to test the response
structure we could again go property by
property
check if the property exists check if
the property has a particular type
check maybe other things about those
properties
with relatively simple responses that is
relatively okay
but once our responses get a bit longer
or are a bit more complex
this approach is no longer so valid a
solution to this is to use a Json schema
and to validate the response that we're
getting against the schema okay let's
back it up for a second what is adjacent
schema adjacent schema is essentially a
way to describe the structures and rules
of our responses
when our responses are in Json we can
use a Json schema
adjacent schema is also written in Json
and essentially helps us understand if
the Json that we're having here actually
follows the expected format and it is a
bit easier to catch errors in that way
so let me show you what I mean by that
we're going to start with a very very
simple test so I'm gonna use here the
test skeleton that we already have
and just one line below I'm gonna write
here schema is valid
and what you will need here is a Json
schema so we're gonna Define here a new
constant call it schema
and what we have here is the assertions
or resolution will be pm.response
and this is going to be one of those
special assertions so we're going to
stay here PM that response to have
Json schema
and we're going to reference here the
schema
so we can simply run it and see
if we're getting anything back
okay
we're getting again the test field the
failed test because of the ID which is
sometimes inconsistent but we're gonna
get here schema is valid okay
so we haven't done a lot in terms of
this schema it's just an empty schema
but just by default it kind of like
passes the test okay fair enough let's
go ahead and actually talk about the
body that we have here about the
structure that we have inside here so
first of all we're gonna say look we
have here an object this is an object
which has properties so we're gonna
write here type
and the type is gonna be object okay
fair enough
then
we can again check is it still working
perfect no problem let's say if we say
type is array
does it fail
okay it fails it says here expecting
data to satisfy schema but found
following errors data should be an array
our data is not an array it's an object
okay so this is a simple way to make
sure that we are on track let's continue
with properties so inside properties
which is again an object we can start
defining the kind of properties we have
in our body so for example ID client ID
created and so on they're all properties
and we can stay for these properties for
example ID is a string client ID is a
string any other information is also a
string
so this should be pretty straightforward
but I'm gonna go ahead and right here we
have the property ID
and again as an object we're gonna write
here type
and the type will be string
okay so we're gonna repeat this a couple
of times so I'm just gonna copy this
code block here make sure to add a comma
and
do this for maybe three or four times
let me make it a bit larger so that you
can see it so we have here ID
the next one on the list is client ID
after this we have created
after created we have customer name
and actually we need another one
but this one is no longer
an ID this is actually an array so we'll
see here products so we can write here
products
column and also as an object type will
be array
very well let's go ahead and run this
and it seems to be working fine
now how do we know if this schema that
we have written here is any good well we
could essentially go ahead and maybe
again play around with stuff and see
string let's change this to a number see
if it fails
and it does fail okay
fair enough seems to be working
but this is a very rudimentary way of
testing if our schema works we need to
find a better way
when we are writing tests in Postman it
is our duty to ensure that this test
will actually fail if needed
if we have tests that never fail when
they should
then we got a problem because then our
tests will not be so useful and we have
wasted a lot of time writing tests that
never fail
now when we're working with Json schema
The Experience shows that writing a
schema that doesn't do what we expect to
do is much much higher than any other
assertions we have written before
so when you're writing a Json schema or
when we're working with Json schema we
need to be extra careful that what our
tests do is actually what we think that
the test should do now testing if the
Json schema works as expected
actually requires us to make some
changes to the response body
well this is easier said than done
because this is the response that is
coming from the API we cannot easily
make changes to it
well luckily we have a built-in Postman
tool that we can use to our advantage
and this is a postman mock servers now
Postman Max servers allows us to create
fake API endpoints so in this context
the word Mark simply means to imitate or
simulate something
it refers to creating a fake version of
the actual API let me put this in plain
terms a mock server will pretend to be
the real API
provide us with some responses to our
requests
but it will not actually process
anything so for example if were to
create a mock endpoint for this create
an order endpoint that mock endpoint
will not save the order will not do any
validation or things like that no the
advantage of using a mock server is that
it allows us to actually test our test
and to ensure that they work as expected
without actually changing the real API
which in most situations we cannot do
anyway so we are going to use this
particular use case for mock servers to
modify the response body so that we can
test our schema now in order to create
our mock the first thing that we need to
do is go to the create a new order
request and click here on save as
example and what this will do is it's
going to save this response body as an
example and this example will be used by
the mock this is the first step that we
need to do and then the second step is
by going over the collection
and hovering over it until this Ellipsis
shows up and from the context menu we're
gonna select Mark collection
what we need to specify here is the mock
server name so for example we can call
it Valentinos
coffee
API mock We're Gonna Save the mock URL
as a new environment variable
and all you need to do next is to click
on create mock server
so the mock server has been created
we can close this tab here
and if we go here over the environment
we'll see here that we have a new
environment this is Valentino's coffee
API mock this is the environment that
stores information about this mock
server and we have there the address we
can go over these environment
and we'll have here this variable URL
we're going to change this to base URL
so that it is the same variable we're
using in our request we'll notice here
we have base URL
and here it should be also base URL when
we don't have an environment selected
we're gonna use the URL that is
configured inside the collection however
when we select an environment
this base URL variable will be
overridden and now we are actually
calling using the exact same request
without making any changes to the
request itself we're now calling the
mock API
so you can notice here I'm running this
once
twice
three times and getting the exact same
information back nothing changes about
it
now if we're looking at the test results
we're gonna see that a few things fail
obviously our mock API doesn't behave
like a real API so for example where we
checking the customer name if it is a
specific name that test is going to fail
we also have this problem with the order
ID so this is something that we can
change here from the response itself so
if we're going over this example EG here
this is an example this is what's being
used by the mock server
see here we remove this
and click on Save
we can check if our test isn't passing
no it's not passing because it's not
long enough so let's add here a new
character
and this schema seems to be valid so the
only problem is the customer name so
let's go back
how can we make sure that this schema is
actually a good schema that it is
working as we expect
what could go wrong with this response
for example
what if we don't have the property
client ID anymore
how can we
stimulate this we go back to this
where we have this essentially
temporary response which you wouldn't
modify
and I'm going to remove here the client
ID all together from the response let's
say some developer has removed it from
the response and we no longer have it
will any test say anything about this
and we can run this again
and if we're looking here at the schema
the schema is valid
that's weird
How about if a developer would add here
a new property for example new property
new prop
I'm gonna call it hello
just for fun adding a new property to
the response body
this should definitely raise the alarm
nope doesn't schema is still valid
so now by using mock servers we can play
around with the response that the server
sends us or doesn't send us and we can
then figure out what can we change about
this to see if the schema will fail if
needed if one of the situations should
occur if we then have a valid test for
that case
well it seems that we don't have a valid
test for that case and the problem with
this is that our schema is valid is a
good schema but it does have some
problem and one of these problems is
that it doesn't say that these
properties are required so yes we have
defined them in the schema if they are
there they're going to be checked to be
a string or an array or anything else
but if they're missing that's not a
problem
if we add new properties that are not
mentioned here that's not a problem so
for this use case this is a problem and
this is something that we can easily
Overlook by looking at this schema and
thinking yeah seems to be working fine
when actually it is not
so what we need to do next here is to
specify another property
and this property will be the required
property so the required property allows
us to specify essentially an array of
values that are required so for example
ID is required
or do we have else client ID it's also
required
created is required everything that we
have here in the response body is
actually required we need to specify
this here
so that when we're doing the schema
validation we're also checking that none
of these properties are missing so we
now saving this let's take a look here
in the response we are still missing
this particular property client ID
so let's see if now
something is failing and yes
now we're getting an error and it's
telling us data should have required
property client ID
but it doesn't
so now we have tested that this
particular feature is working as
expected okay so let's re-enable here
the client ID let's save this
I'm gonna check here again that
everything is working fine schema is
valid perfect
let's add here at the end another
property
I'm gonna call it new
again an additional property that
appeared all of the sudden in our
responses
and we don't know about it
keema is valid how can we change this
Behavior well by default any additional
properties inside the Json data that are
not specified in the schema are allowed
and will not cause the validation to
fail
while this is useful in some situations
in our particular use case it's not what
we want ideally when new data is added
to an API New Field something changes
you want to be alerted about this
because we might want to check that we
may want to write a test about it
and we don't want to be surprised that
something new appeared all of the sudden
so if we don't want any surprises then
we need to specify this explicitly in
our Json schema that we don't allow
additional properties
again this is another setting that we're
gonna add here
so just on the steam level as type
properties required we're gonna write
here additional properties and we're
going to set additional properties to
false we don't allow additional
properties
and now luckily our Json schema is
failing and is telling us data should
not have additional properties
it does have additional properties here
so let's go ahead and remove this from
our mock server
and now our schema is again valid if we
need to check back in with the real API
all we have to do here is disable the
environment
and then we're gonna start interacting
again with the API
but using mock servers is a very
powerful way of working with a schema
defining it and making sure that it
works as expected
writing Json schemas is no easy task and
so far we have just scratched the
surface however I want it to go a bit
deeper and show you a more advanced
example of how we can really ensure that
this response body looks pretty much the
way we expect it to look like
there's still a few flaws here for
example we haven't done anything about
these properties ID and client identity
they can be anything
in terms of created we haven't checked
for a specific format
and also in terms of the products we
just said there must be an array but we
haven't really looked into like the data
structure that these products need to
have here so there's still a bit of work
to be done
now there are a few things that I wanted
to point out first of all we can have
here a string but just as well we can
add here another property which is
called pattern
and this pattern allows us to write here
a regular expression now this time we're
going to write it here between quotes
and in this case we already have Here
regular expression that we can employ so
we're gonna simply go ahead and copy it
from here
and put it here inside a pattern
now apart from this because it is
already between quotes you can go ahead
and remove this
at the beginning and at the end the
forward slashes
and we can go ahead and save this
but not before we remove this other test
which we no longer need
so let's see if this is working properly
seems not to be working properly
let's see why oh actually is a good
example because now we have a character
that we shouldn't have so we already
made the test with this one let's run it
once again
and now the schema is working so
obviously just better luck the first
request went into one of these edge
cases where the ID is not what it should
be
perfect so we have done this here with a
pattern in a pretty similar way we can
do it also for the client ID
but I want you to take a look here at
created so created here is a date so
what we could do here is write for
example a format
and we can say the format needs to be
date time
so this is a date time format let's go
ahead and run it seems to be working
fine
let's switch back to the mock endpoint
just to make sure that in case we're
having here something else that it does
so I'm just going to remove the last
part of this daytime format and make it
a bit shorter let's see if this causes
any issues
and it is going to cause an issue
because it's gonna stay here does not
match the format date time so luckily
again using mock servers can help us
identify if there are any issues at this
point let's switch back to the real API
and take a look at another thing and
these are the products we mentioned
earlier that we have here an array but
we want to go a bit deeper
so we have here an array but this is an
array of objects and we can actually go
a level deeper and say look this is an
array of objects and every object in
this array must have the property ID and
must have the property quantity
so let's see how we can do this as well
essentially when we're having an array
we can then specify items
and items will be then an object where
we can write additional things now the
thing about this is that we're going
back to how we Define an object so this
is super interesting because you can
write here type
and the type will be object
and we can write properties
and we can start writing the kind of
properties that we have
so for example we have here an ID
property
and this is type integer
and just as well we have here a quantity
property
go ahead and copy it from here
and
this is of type
also integer
let's go ahead and see if this works
we're getting here an error Let's Take a
Look Ah probably again the problem with
the ID
no worries we're gonna write once again
so
the schema seems to be working fine
however you need to remember this is an
object so we also need to add here
required
and we're gonna see here that ID is
required and
quantity is required
so if any of these are missing you want
to get notified
if you also want to allow or disallow
additional properties that's a different
discussion but let's give it a try with
this one
schema is valid gonna switch back here
to the mark endpoint
and let's change a few things so I'm
gonna make here ID all in uppercase
just to give it a try Gonna Save this
gonna select the mock environment
and let's try this again to see if this
error is being picked up
and it is being picked up
and it says here should have required
property ID
now we just briefly went over this to
exemplify how we can reduce some of the
tests that we have written previously
and integrate everything in a schema and
still get a pretty decent level of
testing instead of having to write all
these manual tests where we go property
by property and so on
now as we have seen by writing this Json
schema is not really straightforward so
I must warn you that the Json schemas
are a topic on their own and we are just
scratching the surface here
learning to write Json schemas is not
easy
there are two pitfalls I must warn you
about
first of all and I see this all the time
don't use websites which generator
schema for you from a given response
most of the time the schema that you're
getting is simply not good
second of all you're not gonna
understand that schema so it's going to
be very hard for you to determine what
is inside that schema what is actually
being tested and so on and so forth
whatever approach you're taking
always test if the schema will fail if
needed
I've seen so many times complex schemas
being written that simply don't do what
they're supposed to do and we get this
false sense of security because we have
this complex schema which is having all
this regular expressions and is checking
arrays and objects and everything and
then when something changes about the
response the schema says no okay
everything is fine don't worry about it
now if your project is programmatically
generating a Json schema based on its
code and given annotation that is fine
you don't need to write that schema from
scratch you can use it
however this is not a real placement for
understanding what the schema contains
and how to test it
so my advice is if you're just getting
started with Json schemas is to learn
about Json schemas step by step and to
write them on your own
a good resource for learning about Json
schemas is Json Dash
schema.org a link in the course notes
the website is a bit hard to navigate
but if you spend a bit of time and take
a look at the documentation that is
available
you will soon get the hang of it and you
will see how powerful Json schemas are
alright so you have learned so much
about Json schemas
and now it's time for an assessment you
want to really check how you would apply
and create a Json schema for the get
single product endpoint we currently
have all these things here but I want
you to write a Json schema based on what
you have learned from the previous
lectures go ahead to the original
workspace and Fork the assignment number
four inside your workspace and follow
the instructions there
apart from the status code in the
response body a response also has
headers
and we already know how to test the
status code and we know how to work with
response body and make assertions there
but what if there is a header that we
would like to test
while headers tend to be very technical
you may find yourself in a situation
that you want to make an assertion
against a header to make sure that it
has an expected value
for example what if we want to check
here if this x powered by header has the
value expressed
so let's write the test for the headers
I'm just gonna copy here the structure
of the test that we don't have to write
it from scratch
and I'm just gonna write here headers
now before we actually make an assertion
let's make sure that we can actually get
to these headers and for that we're
going to use
pm.response because the headers are in
the response dot headers we'll see here
we have the auto completion four headers
and in order to get a specific header
we're gonna use dot get
and as a string we need to pass the name
of the header so it is best if we go
here in the headers select the name of
the header we want to use
and paste it here this will ensure that
we don't make any mistakes
apart from this let's wrap this up in a
postman console to make sure that we are
getting the right value
right so we're going to open up the
console
clear it
and let's send this request
so what you will see here in a console
is the value Express and this is the
value that we need
okay so it seems that we have everything
that we need so we can go ahead and
write our expectation which would be a
typical expectation that we're going to
write with PM that expect
so what are we expecting well we're
expecting that this value that we're
grabbing from this header to equal
Express
let's go ahead and see if it works and
we have here a new test headers seems to
be passing without any issues and this
is anyway a test structure that we have
used in the past so we know that it is
working
so this is how easy it is to test the
header in Postman
can you imagine testing 100 endpoints in
just a few seconds with Postman you can
do exactly that and I'm here to show you
how you can unlock this super power
welcome to the third level of our API
automation testing challenge we now have
a postman collection with some requests
and each request has the associated test
so we can go through the collection
request by request and all we need to do
is check if the test passed
still this is a manual process and it is
really Time to Say Goodbye to clicking
around in this unit we'll explore
postman's powerful automation tools that
will turn you into an API testing
Rockstar we are entering the most
exciting part of this course where all
the effort we have been putting into
writing this test pays off so let's Dive
In
before we jump into automating things we
need to make sure that the request as it
is right now is working without any
issues so what we need to do is to go
through every request
standard request
and check here the test results
so we need to do this for every request
in this collection because if we have
some issues at this point then it
doesn't make sense to automate it so we
need to check that all the test results
are passing
now once we have done that this is when
we can talk about the Automation and the
first tool I wanted to show you is the
postman collection Runner so the postman
collection Runner is a tool that allows
us to run this entire collection with
just a single click of a button so just
remember all the work that you did for
this just a few requests here if you
have maybe 20 30 100 requests that you
need to send that's a lot of work so we
can replace all that with just the click
of a button so let me show you how it
works and it's super super easy all you
have to do is go over our collection
until this Ellipsis shows up and from
the menu we're gonna select run
collection this will open up a new tab
and this is the postman collection run
so let me briefly explain what we're
seeing here
on the left hand side here we see a list
of all our requests now the way requests
are executed in Postman is by the order
that we have in the collection so
essentially post model will go folder by
folder and grab all the requests that
are inside there and we'll display them
here
of course sometimes maybe this is not
the way we want to have this but that's
not the problem we can easily drag and
drop requests anywhere else
so we can move requests around if we're
not happy with a particular execution
order
apart from this there can be situations
where we say for example register a new
client we have already executed that
request manually so we don't really want
to automate that we can disable that
all right so this is the order in which
this request will be executed the
postman collection Runner will execute
this request from top to bottom so it
will start with get API status get all
products and so on and so forth in this
order
now on the right hand side we need to
choose how we want to run our collection
and the first option that is already
selected is run manually this is what we
want to do
apart from this there are also some
other settings but they are not relevant
at this point so all you need to do is
click on this big orange run button and
start automating this collection run
with just a single click
now look at this magic as Postman goes
through all this requests that we have
and in a matter of essentially second
the entire collection has been executed
and now we have the results we know what
has happened so what has happened we
have here all the tests and we see here
past 11. so 11 tests have passed none
have failed
now of course we can find ourselves in a
situation where maybe one of the tests
is failing
of course we know that this API has an
issue and if we run this a couple of
times one of these schema validations
will fail because the idea of the order
doesn't match the given pattern
if that is the case what we will see
here is we have how many have passed and
we'll see here failed now generally
we're not interested in how many have
passed but we're interested in why
something has failed so we'll get you
information about okay create a new
order has failed and we're getting here
the reason why this has failed
now if you're trying to debug this a bit
deeper
we'll notice here that the response is
not available it says your response body
is not available and this is a bit of a
bummer because
without the response body we can't
really understand what has happened but
we're also given here information that
hey you can change this in the Run
configuration right so let's go back to
the Run configuration and what has
happened this time is that postman has
set this flag for us
persist responses in a session so by
default for performance reasons Postman
doesn't save the response body doesn't
allow you to take a look at it and see
what has happened
but if we enable this one it is very
powerful because it will allow us to
take a look at the response and
understand what has happened
now there's another setting that I want
to show you
and this one is the iteration
this bug that we're experiencing only
occurs from time to time
so either we can manually click maybe
three four five six times through that
run button until the error occurs or we
can see from the beginning look just run
this 10 times for example and I will
take a look and see which of these times
didn't work and I can investigate that
in particular
so let's go ahead and click that run
button once again
and you can see here Postman is doing
the heavy lifting for us everything is
in place
imagine just the work that would have to
do to run this request so many times and
inspect all the tests and see if
everything is working well
okay so in this situation we have
executed this so many times nothing has
failed so let's try it again
and what you will see here is that some
of our runs have failed so this is
another opportunity to go ahead and
investigate what has happened and we're
gonna see it is the create new order
request that is constantly failing so
that's a good thing that there's nothing
else that is failing
but let's this time take a look and see
what is wrong with this now we'll
actually have access to the response and
we'll see oh look at this character this
is not what we expect according to the
schema this is why this test is failing
so in a nutshell this is how we can use
the postman collection Runner to run our
collection with a click of a button and
then if something fails we can dive into
the results and understand what is the
reason for the failure
using the postman collection Runner is
the first step that we need to take just
to verify that we can actually automate
our collection run so this is going to
be probably the first thing that we want
to do just to manually run the
collection a couple of times to make
sure that everything is working fine
but this is still a semi-automatic step
because we need to open a collection we
need to go inside it we need to open the
postman collection Runner we need to
click that button we need to inspect the
results and everything
now there is also the possibility in
Postman of scheduling a run so
essentially when scheduling a run we are
no longer executing the postman
collection on our personal computer
we're not using Postman at all
instead the execution takes place on the
postman cloud
so there's no need to keep a postman
open or even our computer can be turned
off during this process so this is
essentially a fully automated collection
run
in order to schedule a run all you have
to do is hover over the collection click
on the Ellipsis and from the context
menu we're gonna select run collection
by default we have here run manually but
just as well we can select the option
schedule runs
so when we are scheduling a run we are
taking our collection and running it in
the postman cloud
in this case we can also decide which is
the order in which we want to execute
this request or if there are any
requests that we would like to disable
like registering a new client
apart from this on the lower part there
are also a few things that we need to
configure we should give this schedule a
name for example if you wanna run this
once per week or once per day we can
decide this here just going to give it a
name weekly API test
and then we can select the Run frequency
and this can be like every hour every
week every day and so on
in this case
we are on the week timer
so we can decide we want to run it every
day or we want to run it every weekday
because if it fails on a Sunday and
nobody is going to be in the office to
take a look at the results or maybe we
can decide just to run this once per
week let's say that we want to run it
every weekday and we're gonna decide
when do we want to run it probably early
in the morning would be a good choice
apart from this we can also get email
notifications and you can also add other
people there
is also some advanced settings that you
may want to look into but they're not
relevant for what we're trying to do
right now
let's go ahead and click on schedule run
so in this case we're going to get
information about when is this run
scheduled
scheduling is a good way to keep an eye
on an already deployed API to see if it
is still working as expected in other
words we are monitoring the API if there
are any issues this will be reported and
will get a notification
running this at regular intervals also
allows us to understand the time frame
when a problem occurred if one occurs
now of course we have the option of
waiting until this collection will be
automatically executed
just to make sure that you know
everything is working fine in theory
before we wait for the first run we can
manually click on run now but if we
don't do this
Postman will do this for us from the
cloud so when we're clicking here on a
run now this is not the same as manually
running the collection on our own
computer now we are using the postman
Cloud to run this collection
now instantly we're gonna get some
information here we're gonna get
information that this is unhealthy so
there's some problems with this API
and apart from this we're gonna see here
how many tests have failed and what is
going on and why these tests have failed
now we can notice here a few things for
example get API status seems to be
working fine getting all products get
single products everything works well
until we start working with requests
that have authentication we're gonna get
here the status 403 Forbidden
now this can be a bit confusing because
we have executed this collection locally
and it worked without any issues so why
is this failing now well the thing is
the following you need to remember that
inside our collection we have stored a
secret so if we go inside the collection
and edit it
and jump to the variables we're gonna
see here that we have some secrets we
have this API key
now the current value this is what we
have here on our computer
however when we're sharing this
collection and in this case we're also
sharing our collection with the postman
cloud
Postman
from the cloud only has access to this
information
and as you can notice here we don't have
a valid API key
now we can change our workflow in a way
that this information is available so
that we generate an API key when we're
running this flow or what's a bit
quicker in our situation we can simply
go ahead and take this from the current
value
and put it here in the initial value
now you need to be very careful with
this because remember this workspace is
public
anything that is in the initial value is
for this particular collection this API
key is Not So problematic but you may
find yourself in a different setting and
in that case exposing this API key as an
initial value may not be such a good
idea
but typically when you're trying to run
a collection
and you're having authentication issues
when using a schedule run
but the exact same run is working
without any problems when you're using
the manual run install Postman
probably 99 of the cases this is related
to postman variables
so remember the postman cloud is only
using this initial value doesn't have
access to the current value
so this is just a small hack to ensure
that this is not working properly
so let's go ahead over the collection
and we can open here the tab runs
and we can see here that we have
scheduled runs
so this is our schedule here
and we can click on view to go back to
the previous View that we had
so all we have to do now is Click again
on run
wait a few seconds
and we'll see now that our API is
healthy meaning everything that we have
inside our collection is working as
expected well the requests are working
as expected all the tests are working as
expected there are no script errors or
anything like that
of course we can also go into the
details and see the test results and see
which tests have been executed and the
fact that they have passed but this is
less relevant also have access to the
console log and see if there's any
details here that might interest us
but apart from this there's nothing else
that we need to do here so typically we
are going here when something doesn't
work anymore when we get an alert that
our API has issues now this tool can be
very valuable for verifying that your
public API operates as intended
particularly in relation to
configuration updates or recent
deployments so it's just a good idea if
you're having a public API to schedule
one of these runs and let it run at a
regular interval so that you get
information about this if something goes
wrong you will be notified
now pre-production environments are
usually not publicly accessible which
somehow restricts the usage of this
feature professional and Enterprise
plans provide access to a static IP
address that can be configured as a
firewall exception but that's a separate
conversation on its own
now once you have understood how this
scheduled runs work it is also best once
you don't need them anymore to simply
delete them so all you have to do is
again go here inside the collection go
to the runs tab
and then all you have to do is hover
over the scheduled run that you have
click on the Ellipsis and either pause
it or delete it all together
so in a nutshell scheduling a run
essentially creates a monitor which runs
at a predefined interval and keeps an
eye on your API and ensure that it's
still working properly
in this lecture I will introduce you to
the postman CLI a tool that runs a
postman collection using the command
line we'll learn its Basics setup and
how to use it for a more efficient API
testing process
in order to get started with a postman
CLI again we're gonna hover over the
collection until this Ellipsis shows up
and select run collection
from the options available here this
time we're gonna select here automate
runs via CLI
once we do this we're gonna get
instructions on how to use Postman CLI
to run this collection but first of all
we need to install
so let's go ahead and download Postman
CLI
to install Postman CLI we need to follow
a few steps
I'm going to demonstrate this process in
Windows because most of you are using
Windows but it works in a similar way
for Mac OS and Linux
first of all you need to open a terminal
window if you never did this before
that's absolutely fine
simply search for a program called
Powershell
if you are on a Mac you need to search
for a program called terminal
and if you're on a Linux you're probably
done with installing this by now anyway
let's go back to Windows you will see
this window where you can type in
commands
let me make this a bit bigger for you
now if we're going back to the
documentation
we'll see here that we have installation
instructions for Windows Mac
and Linux
so for every operating system there is a
different command so for Windows all you
have to do is copy this command
if you have a newer Mac you probably
have the newer CPU for Mac so you may
want to use this first command if your
Mac is a bit older you use this one
and for Linux you have this command at
the end so I'm going to copy this one
for Windows
and we'll have to paste it in the
terminal window that we have open
you can use your keyboard shortcuts or
simply click on the window bar and use
the context menu to paste
after this the command will show up and
you need to press the enter key to
execute the command
the installation should only take a few
minutes
to ensure that the installation has been
successful we need to type in the
following command
Postman
space
minus V
and this will print out the current
Postman version
now when you're seeing this process and
all these weird commands you're probably
like are you sure is this a good idea I
mean why do we need this can we go back
to this nice Postman interface that we
had before
and I can totally understand
a command line interface tool CLI tool
is invaluable for streamlining the
testing process as it allows for
automation easy integration with
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipelines and overall a
faster execution
apart from this we can also run a
postman collection on our own
infrastructure without using the posting
cloud
let me put this plainly if we want to
let the computer run our Postman
collection without our human
intervention we need to use a CLI tool
if we wish to run Postman tests in a CI
CD server like Jenkins GitHub actions or
gitlab we need to use a CLI tool we
cannot use the graphical interface from
Postman
so let's jump back into Postman and try
to run our collection using the postman
CLI
now if we're looking here on the lower
part we're gonna get here instructions
about some commands we need to run and
they're essentially to command one of
them is Postman login
and the other one is a command that will
actually run the collection
now let's just copy the last command
that you see here
jumping into the terminal I'm gonna
paste it
and what we're gonna get here is an
error it's going to tell us that no
authorization data was found and that we
need to use the postman login command
now whenever you're getting errors when
using these tli tools
it's important not to just panic because
there is an error but just take a bit
the time to read line by line understand
what has happened you have executed a
command and then the tool is telling you
no authorization data was found and
sometimes these tools teacher to be
helpful in telling you hey you need to
use Postman login
so obviously we have missed something
here we first need to run the First
Command which is Postman login okay how
do we run this let's copy this command
here
and we're going to paste it again and
again we're gonna get an error now when
we're trying to log in with an API key
in this case we actually need to provide
that API key
and the graphical interface here is
trying to help us you like you don't
have an API key let's how about you add
one here so we're going to click here on
ADD API key
and we can either use an existing key
that we have or we can simply click here
on generate key
we can call this key Postman CLI so that
we know what we have created it
and click on generate
okay no spaces are allowed let's put
this together
and now we have a key and we can click
here on insert key
so this key then will be part of this
command here so all we need to do then
is to copy this entire command
go back here and paste it
so the First Command will log us in
and the second command will execute the
postman collection so let's see how this
will go
so we're gonna see here a few issues
but first of all we have been logged in
successfully and then we can actually
see our API here but then we're getting
some errors here now the first error is
a type error and we're going to take a
look at the logs to understand what is
going on and the second one is coming
here from the orders and this is
probably the schema that has failed in
the past so that's nothing to worry
about so the first error is actually
complaining that in the get API status
request we have this console clear
function so it's telling us this is not
a function so obviously Postman CLI
doesn't know about console.clear or
doesn't make sense to have a console got
clear in this context so we need to
figure out a way around that
and the second assertion error is that
schema is valid but apart from this this
is how we can run a collection using
Postman CLI and we can take a look here
and see all the requests that have been
executed we'll have here essentially a
report at the end so we know how many
requests have failed how many requests
are still working and so on
let's jump back into Postman and try to
fix this console.clearprom
so what we can do here in the status
request get API status
and in a prequest script you see here we
have console.clear
so what we could do here is we could add
an if statement so if console.clear
without actually calling it
and we're going to move the statement
inside here
we can quickly verify if the console is
still being cleared let's send this
request
so we see console was cleared we have
saved this request
and then if we need to run this once
again all we need is the second command
because postman has logged us in
so when we're trying to run any other
commands here we don't need to log in
once again because we are already logged
in
so all we need to do is use this command
Postman collection run and this thing
that we see here this is actually the
internal ID of the collection this is
how Postman identifies our collection
and now we have apparently got rid of
that issue with console.clear and we
still have this problem with the schema
is valid
now apart from this we're also getting
information that this execution has been
uploaded to the postman cloud
so what does that mean well it means
that we can see this detail inside
Postman let me show you
go back to postman
and click on our collection
we're gonna see here the Run step
and what we'll be able to see here are
test runs and we have here the source so
we have here the source being Postman
CLI or Runner which means the manual run
that we have used and we can also dig
here into the results and see what is
going on
for example we're gonna click here on
this icon to view the report
and we can take a look and see what
exactly has failed and hopefully what is
the reason for this and of course if you
need to troubleshoot this we can go back
to either running the request manually
in Postman or using the manual
collection Runner to run this collection
from the beginning to see if whatever
error we have encountered is still
occurring now as you can see the
response body is also not available so
this is something that we need to change
in the Run configuration but for Postman
cli's this is not something that we can
do at this moment so this is why we need
to run this manually to see if we can
replicate that specific issue
when you're using the postman CLI to run
a postman collection that actually a lot
of things that you can configure that
are not visible here directly in post
now to understand how you can use
Postman CLI like like a pro it is
important to spend a bit of time and go
over the postman CLI documentation and
its command options essentially whenever
we're running a command like Postman
collection run
we can also specify some additional
options that change the behavior of this
command
now there are a lot of options here and
I highly recommend going over them and
seeing if you may want to use them
sometime in the future at least to note
that they are available and that this is
possible
however there is something that I wanted
to show you just to give you an idea on
how we can use this
let's say that in our collection run
we only want to run a specific folder
and for this we can use this option
minus I and specify the folder name
let me show you how it works
all I have to do is go back to postman
and let's just copy again only the
command that runs the entire collection
in Postman CLI I'm going to go ahead and
paste this
and after this I'm going to add here
space then minus I
and then between quotes
I'm going to put here a name of the
folder that I want to execute
for the sake of this let's just say I
want to execute status so only the
requests that are inside status I want
to execute them
I'm going to write inside here status
let's go ahead and run this
and what you will see this time is that
only one request has been executed
because now with this additional option
we have configured the way this
collection run functions so only one
request has been executed and this is
sometimes very powerful because we can
decide to run only a couple of folders
so for example if you need to run only
three folders from a collection then you
can just use minus I the name of a
folder and then after this also the
other folders Let me Give an example
let's say one run status and then
there's another folder that way we want
to use products
I'm gonna write here product as well
and you will see here that only status
and products as folders have been
executed
again it's super important that you go
over the documentation and understand
what these options do and how you can
use them
welcome to the last level of our API
automation testing game in this unit
we'll be tackling the integration of
Postman tests in cicd in the upcoming
lessons my goal is to help you
understand why this is important and how
to do it integrating Postman API tests
in a cicd pipeline is essential because
it automates the testing process
ensuring that apis are continuously
validated and function as expected
during development and deployment let me
put this in simpler terms where
basically firing ourselves from the
testing department and letting computers
take over while we still keep a watchful
eye to make sure nothing goes Haywire we
will kick things off by discussing the
fundamentals of cicd and the importance
it holds in our testing process next
we'll embark on a step-by-step journey
to run Postman tests using GitHub action
one of the leading cicd tools out there
if you are using a different CI CD
Solution that's also fine I will provide
you with some guidance on how to get
started with other tools as well apart
from this we will talk about Postman
workspaces reports and effective
collaboration techniques within your
team if you have been following Along on
this Grand Adventure give yourself a
hearty pad on the back this is the fun
part so grab your gear and let's Dive In
let's talk about cicd for a second
the ICD stands for continuous
integration and continuous deployment
it is a practice used in software
development to make the process faster
and more reliable
with continuous integration every time a
developer changes the software those
changes are tested automatically this
helps catch any problems early in the
process
once the CI pipeline is done we start
the CD pipeline where we typically
deploy the software to a test
environment which allows us to do
further tests
if all tests pass the changes are
automatically deployed to the production
environment and go live
this practice allows for improvements
that can be made quickly without having
to wait for a big update
this process helps teams work together
more efficiently
and it makes easier to keep the software
running smoothly
now what does this have to do with
Postman tests and automation well the
thing is if we're working on an API
using CI CD it makes absolute sense
and we also want to integrate our
Postman API test in the CI CD pipeline
there are at least two steps in the
process where it makes sense to run
Postman tests
after deploying the API to a
pre-production environment such as a
test environment and after deploying to
the production environment
using the postman CLI allows us to run a
postman collection and the associated
tests in our continuous deployment
pipeline without us manually triggering
a run
let's talk for a second about the ICD
providers using a CI CD tool allows us
to automate the process of integrating
code changes testing and deploying
applications making our lives easier now
it is important to understand that there
isn't a single best tool for CI CD the
best tool for you will depend on your
specific needs your team's familiarity
with the tool and the specific
requirements of your project your
organization may already use a tool so
you could be forced to use whatever
option is available anyway
some popular solutions for cicd include
Jenkins gitlab
Circle CI and GitHub actions among
others in the upcoming lesson I'm going
to show you how to use Postman CLI to
run a collection in GitHub actions
now I want to make it clear that this
isn't intended as an introduction to
GitHub action we're focusing here on how
to use Postman CLI within the context of
GitHub actions if you are not familiar
with GitHub actions that is absolutely
fine I will take you through the process
step by step
now you might be using a different CI CD
tool and that's perfectly fine the
beauty of Postman CLI is that once you
understand how to use it integrating it
in any cicd server is relatively
straightforward the principles we'll
cover here can be applied to other cicd
tools as well
before we start you will need to sign up
for a free GitHub account if you don't
already have one GitHub actions is a
feature of GitHub so you need to have an
account to be able to use it signing up
is relatively easy and quick and it will
give you access to a wide range of tools
and resources Beyond just GitHub actions
so let's go ahead and run bothman API
test with GitHub actions for that we're
gonna need a GitHub repository so let's
go ahead and create a new repository I'm
gonna name the repository my API project
and also want to make sure that this
repository is public
let's go ahead and click on create
Repository
in order to configure a pipeline with
GitHub actions we need to go here from
the project page to actions
and we're going to set up a workflow
ourselves essentially a workflow is
something that we want to execute with
the help of GitHub action
I'm going to call this workflow Postman
and here we will have to put in the
configuration that is needed to run our
Postman collection using Postman CLI now
luckily we don't have to write
everything from scratch but we have
postpon on our site to help us with this
process
so what I'm going to do next is I'm
going to jump here inside Postman
hover over the collection and select a
run collection from the option
then gonna go to automate runs via CLI
and what you will notice here on the
lower part of the screen is run in CI CD
a little bit hidden and I wouldn't be
surprised if you missed this before so
let's go ahead and click on configure
command
because with this tool here we'll be
able to configure our pipeline in just a
few seconds
so first of all we want to make sure
that we have the right collection here
and then from the list of cicd providers
we're gonna select GitHub action
and what we'll see here is the command
that we need to execute
so let's go ahead and copy this command
I'm gonna jump back to GitHub actions
and here in this window
I'm gonna paste this
now this is a git repository so we need
to commit these changes
and we can just go with the defaults
here and click on Commit
so now our project contains
a folder which is dot GitHub forward
slash workflows
and inside here we have our
configuration file and this should run
our Postman collection
if you want to see what exactly is
happening we can click here on view runs
or you can simply go here to actions
now if we take a look at one of these
workflow runs here
we're able to see if they were
successful or not
so in essence we have here
a job which is called automated API test
we can go on it and we'll see it is red
so it's already not looking good
but when something doesn't work it is
important to understand what has
happened
so you'll see here there are various
steps that are happening I don't know
setting up the job running something and
then this is the part that is
interesting for us it is installing
Postman CLI because it is not installed
so you'll see here okay Postman CLI has
been installed this work without any
issues
and it is trying to log into Postman CLI
and it's going to tell us hey there's
some argument missing here
so again we haven't specified the API
key and what we definitely don't want to
do is to put that API key inside our
code so we're not going to put any keys
in our configuration
so how can we handle this well if we're
looking back at the configuration we're
going to see here that there is
something that is referencing an API key
so let's open up here postman.yamu
and what you're going to see here is
something with secrets that Postman
underscore API underscore key
every CI CD system out there will allow
you to store some secrets so let's go
ahead and do exactly that I'm going to
copy here Postman underscore API
underscore key and go to settings for
this project
and then under security here
you should see secrets and variables
we're gonna select from the list actions
and this allows us to define a new
repository Secret
so let's go ahead and click on new
repository stick wrap we're gonna give
it this name that we have just copied
from the pipeline
then from Postman we need a secret key
so from here from Postman we can see
here again the option of generating an
API key
and this time we're gonna write here
GitHub action
and this is very helpful because then we
know that this API key is associated
with GitHub actions so you can simply go
ahead and copy this entire thing
and paste it here and then click on ADD
Secret
now I'm showing this openly because I'm
going to revoke these secrets later on
just in case you're wondering but I want
you to understand exactly how this
process works and how these secrets look
like it's also important that you name
them exactly as you see and that you
don't add any spaces or any other
characters new line and things like that
to them otherwise they tend not work so
well
let's go back to actions here
and we can take a look at one of these
runs that has failed here and we can
simply click on this button rerun jobs
this will essentially restart this job
so now the job has started
and we can even click on it to see what
is it doing
and we can see the installation part is
done
it has logged in into the postman CLI
so we have that information there
and then now we're running some API
tests
and we can see here what is going on
with API tests
and we have the exact same report that
we see when we're running Postman CLI
locally but this time it is running in
the cloud
now whenever something goes wrong with
this you need to determine is this
because there was an issue executing the
postman collection so essentially a
postman test has failed or is it a
problem with a script that we have
written
in any case it is important to have the
patience to go over the logs and
understand what has happened if there
are some errors it's important to
understand if there are any hints or any
information here in this log so don't
get scared that you see some failures
here that's absolutely normal actually
you want to make sure that whatever
we're doing here actually fails if they
need to fail
just as running Postman CLI locally when
we're running Postman CLI with the help
of a cicd provider like GitHub actions
the results of this execution will be
published to postman so you can go back
inside Postman
and if we close the steps and click on
the collection name itself we'll see
here runs
and this time we're going to see again
information about the one that just
happened there are also additional
information here so you can see here
this is the second build this is being
linked actually to GitHub action so we
can click on it and see more details
about this what has happened why
something has failed
but just as well we can also visualize
the results that we have from within
Postman
I hope you have managed to follow along
because now it's time for another
assignment
it is super important that you
understand how to use Postman CLI and if
you manage to run the API test with the
help of GitHub actions then essentially
your job is done if you haven't done
that please go to the previous lecture
and tried it once again because for this
assignment you will need your GitHub
repository and you need to submit your
guitar repository in order to be able to
complete this final assignment anyway go
to the original Postman workspace work
the assignment number five and follow
all the details that you will find
inside there
if you are not using GitHub actions that
is also absolutely fine
you can run Postman CLI in virtually any
CI CD system out there however for the
most popular ones Postman makes your
life a bit easier so when you're going
here over your collection and selecting
a run collection
then automating via CLI and then under
run on cicd you click on configure
command
what you will see here are different
cicd providers that you can use so you
have bit pocket pipelines Circle CI
gitlab Jenkins Azure pipelines Travis CI
and probably many others in the near
future
apart from this you can also go and
select the operating system where this
provider is running so if there are any
particularities if you know that this is
running for example on Windows then you
can also select the operating system
there and what you will be given here is
the configuration that you can use to
get started with this and this of course
changes depending on the provider but
for most situations this is just enough
to get started just enough to see that
these tests are executing in your cicd
pipeline and then you can make
improvements based upon this but in a
nutshell what you need to do is you need
to ensure that Postman CLI is installed
you need to make sure that you are all
dedicated and that you don't expose your
API credentials anywhere in the pipeline
configuration
and then you need to run the postman
collection run command specifying the ID
of your collection
and after this the results of this
execution will be displayed in your CI
CD system and will also be ingested into
Postman so that you can see the reports
from the collection itself
Postman is all about collaboration most
of the time when you're using Postman
you want to collaborate with other
people in your team
for that you need a team and you need to
use team workspace
so not to create a team workspace all
you have to do is go here to workspaces
and click on create workspace
next if it's not already selected you
need to select your team
let's call this workspace my
API
my account doesn't have a team so a team
will be created as well
so let's go ahead and go directly to the
workspace
and let's see what we can do here
team workspaces allow you to collaborate
on a collection
you can create Forks
essentially which are a copy of a
collection
when you're working on a collection and
making changes of course you can also
collaborate with others and comment and
have conversations with others within
your team to understand why some changes
are made or why maybe something isn't
working as expected
and you're also able to track everything
that is going on within your collection
knowing exactly who has made which
changes and most importantly why
when you're working with many many apis
it's also super helpful to be able to
search around and to find what you're
looking for
okay so let's go ahead and see exactly
how we can benefit from this team
workspaces and especially how we can
benefit from working Collections and
merging changes into them so let's go
ahead and switch back to our Dark theme
and I'm going to make this a bit bigger
for you so that you can properly see
we're gonna go ahead and create a new
collection and I'm going to call this
collection Postman Echo
but let's imagine that we want to
collaborate on this collection but we
don't want to make changes directly to
the collection in that case what we can
do is hover over the collection until
this menu pops up
and then we can select create Fork so
then we're creating a fork of this
particular collection but receiving it
in the same workspace so this will be my
Fork we can give it any other label for
example we can call it new request
because let's say we want to work on a
new request we're gonna Fork this
collection we're gonna have an exact
copy of this collection
and in this new collection we can go
ahead and add a request
and let's say for example we want to add
a request to the following endpoints so
we're going to use Postman Dash
echo.com forward slash get this will be
a very simple request against this API
which is provided by Postman and we're
gonna get here some information back not
so relevant just gonna go ahead and save
this and close this so our original
collection doesn't have any request now
we have added a request here just want
to test it a bit to make sure it works
then we'll say okay now we want to
integrate these changes back into the
previous collection because we know that
everything will be done here adding The
Collection maybe writing some tests and
other script everything works as
expected what we can do is we're gonna
go over our fork and from the context
menu
we can do two things we can create a
pull request which essentially is a
request for merging these changes back
into original collection or simply
merging the changes
now of course this depends on the
permissions that you have sometimes you
can merge changes but sometimes you can
only create a pull request so let's go
ahead and do that
so it's a pull request we have to
provide here some information like why
are we making these changes to the
collection so for example you can say
that a title is added request and we can
provide here a description like we have
added another request which is necessary
for whatever project we're working on we
can also add here reviewers from our
team and then we can go ahead and create
that pull request
so we can see here a few things so we'll
be able to see exactly what has been
added
so we'll see it's a new request it is
with the method get and this is the URL
where this request is going so here you
will be given an overview of everything
that has changed in that collection
and it's important to notice here that
we are having this particular source
with a label that we have specified and
we want to integrate these changes in
the original collection so this is the
original collection this is the one that
we have for
now depending on how things are
configured we may or may not have the
permission to merge
in this case we do have the permission
to merge so this merge pattern appears
here so we're gonna go ahead and click
on it and here there are various options
that we can consider essentially once we
merge these changes we don't need the
copy that we have made the one with the
label so in this case I'm going to
select the merge changes and delete
Source but you can just go ahead and
click on merge changes and manually
delete it later on if you feel more
comfortable so let's go ahead and click
on merge
so the pull request has been merged
so the changes that we have proposed are
now inside this collection
in a nutshell this is a very simple
workflow that you and your team can use
when working on a postman collection in
a collaborative way and you want to keep
track of which changes are being made
and most importantly why
we are coming towards the end of the
course and it is time for you to claim
your Postman badge for completing this
course and doing all those assignments
now go to the original workspace and
Fork The Collection named claim your
badge
inside there you'll find detailed
instructions on what you need to do in
order to claim that badge I hope you
have been able to follow along and do
all the assignments if you need any help
or you got stuck please refer to the
course notes for every individual
assignment
congratulations you reached the grand
finale of this API test automation
course with Postman give yourself a pat
on the back or even a round of applause
yes because you have earned it my friend
I hope you had as much fun learning as I
did teaching sure it was a bit of work
but who says we can't enjoy a little
brain workout right
API testing and automation with Postman
can be a bit of a maze but I aimed to
guide you through this as smooth as
possible of course some things just
couldn't fit into the course but don't
worry the course notes for this lesson
have got you covered with both free and
paid resources to help you continue your
Postman Journey just like you Postman
and apis are constantly growing and
evolving so make sure to keep up to date
in this ever-changing world of API
testing it was a pleasure having you
throughout this course and I can't wait
to see many of you proudly wearing that
Postman badge on social media and when
you do so don't forget to tag me it will
make my day if you enjoyed this course
I'll be thrilled if you could check out
my YouTube channel for more amazing
content and smash that subscribe button
your support will keep me fired up to
create more content like this one and
while you're at it please show some love
to the sponsor of this course Postman
with that I just want to say a massive
thank you for joining me in this
adventure and I hope to see you again in
the next one until then Happy testing
with Postman